Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 263, das sich mit wichtigen Dingen beschäftigt, könnte man so sagen. Wir leben ja gerade in aufregenden Zeiten und in aufregenden Zeiten gibt es Dinge, die funktionieren und Dinge, die nicht funktionieren. Und dass manche Dinge nicht funktionieren, ist nicht so schlimm, solange es nicht folgende Sachen sind. Systemrelevante Berufe und kritische Infrastruktur. Was hat das aber mit dem Chaosradio zu tun? Na ja, bei der kritischen Infrastruktur in einer digitalen Welt gibt es kritische IT-Infrastruktur. Oder ist es kritische Infrastruktur, die IT-Komponenten hat? Und was passiert, wenn die kaputt geht? Und was kann man dagegen machen? Und das ist exakt das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Und ich werde versuchen, für euch zu verstehen, oder für und mit euch zu verstehen, was wir heute hier besprechen. Zu Gast sind zwei Hauptpersonen der sogenannten AG Kritis. Was das ist, werden wir heute auch besprechen. Sie sind HonkHase und Ijon. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. So, ihr seid bei AG Kritis. Wir werden noch genau erklären, was das ist und wofür man das braucht und was das kaputt macht. Und auch vielleicht wieder ganz. Aber was seid ihr denn noch? Weil das ist ja nicht alles, was ihr macht. Vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch ein bisschen vorstellen, wer eigentlich im normalen Leben, solange man heutzutage noch davon sprechen kann, seit HonkHase, vielleicht fängst du an.
Ja, in meinem beruflichen Leben arbeite ich als Senior Manager bei der High Solutions AG und berate oder prüfe kritische Infrastrukturen, um da die Schutzmaßnahmen entsprechend aufzusetzen, umzusetzen oder sicherzustellen oder danach zu prüfen. Und ansonsten bilde ich auch kritische Infrastrukturprüfe aus oder evaluiere mit an diversen IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, EU, NIS-Richtlinie und so weiter und so fort. In meinem privaten Leben befasse ich mich mit Themen wie, naja, kritische Infrastrukturen, weil das auch...
Ich erkenne ein Muster.
Ja, ehrenamtlich, privat und irgendwie auch beruflich, genau. Aber auch um sowas wie Hackback, Ethik und Moral und Katastrophenschutz sozusagen in digitaler Natur, sprich Cyberresilienz und wie kann man das eigentlich sicherstellen bei der ganzen IP-Iffizierung dieser ganzen Landschaft?
Also du bist sozusagen mit Leib und Seele beim Thema dabei. Ich könnte mir fast schon vorstellen, dass du ein bisschen traurig wärst, wenn irgendwann Sachen nicht mehr kaputt gehen können.
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Das ist ja das Heereziel und das wird man auch nie erreichen. Insofern gibt es da immer was zu tun. Aber ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn ich deutlich weniger zu tun hätte, weil dann die ethisch-moralische Ausrichtung und die Cyberresilienz entsprechend angepasst wären, wie es mein Traum wäre.
Okay, gut. Wir haben jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit, um zu besprechen, wie wir uns dem vielleicht annähern. Ijon, was machst du noch, wenn du nicht, warte, die Frage, wie HonkHase sein Leben gerade erklärt hat, kann ich die Frage so nicht stellen.
Was machst du so? Tagsüber arbeite ich im Deutschen Bundestag für einen Abgeordneten dort, den Abgeordneten Mario Brandenburg, der sich mit Technologie, Politik, Netzpolitik, Digitalthemen, Technikfolgen beschäftigt. Mario ist Mitglied, im Gegensatz zu mir, der Partei der Freien Demokraten und besitzt für selbige auch ein Mandat im Deutschen Bundestag. Als Vollmitglied im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda ist es dann meine Verantwortung, ihn zu den Ausschussthemen, das Ausschuss Digitale Agenda, zu beraten und ansonsten bin ich Lobbytarget und kriege deswegen mit, wie Lobbyismus von innen funktioniert. Natürlich wollen Lobbyisten mit mir reden und ich bin auf der Empfängerseite der ganzen Geschichte.
Das ist ganz spannend. Also das Ziel der Lobbyisten ist ja der MDB, aber weil der viel zu tun hat.
Der Weg ist über mich.
Und der Weg ist über die Referenten und so, ja verstehe, verstehe, verstehe. Okay, wir machen heute, ich weiß nicht, ob wir heute keine Parteipolitik machen. Wir machen heute keine grundsätzliche Parteipolitik, so, um das mal klarzumachen, sondern dann kämen wir zu nichts, dann wäre diese Infrastruktur kaputt. Sondern wir wollen uns heute mit kritischer Infrastruktur.
Ich würde vielleicht auch noch kurz sagen, was ich zu meiner Freizeit tue.
Ach so, warte mal. Weil in meiner Freizeitspiele ich mit... Stopp, Referenten von MDBs haben Freizeit?
Ja, ich wundere mich auch gerade. Wenn es keine Sitzungswoche ist, kommt das vor. Also wenn jetzt diese Woche, also dieses Jahr haben wir jetzt noch zwei Sitzungsfreie Wochen. Wir haben jetzt in den neunmal diesen Zehnten, falls Leute das im Nachhinein hören. Und den Rest der Wochen sind komplett Sitzungswochen. Das wird sehr anstrengend. Aber es gibt auch Sitzungsfreie Zeit und da hat man auch mal Freizeit, ja. Und in der Zeit kümmere ich mich und spiele gerne mit großen Maschinen. Solche, die von OT gesteuert werden tatsächlich. Meistens große CNC-Fräsen oder sonstige größere Maschinen, mit denen ich dann meine Freizeit verbringen möchte.
Warte mal, größere Maschinen, die Dinge zersägen. HonkHase beschäftigt sich damit, wie man Dinge nicht kaputt macht. Kritische Infrastruktur, doch, weil im Vorhinein auch in Twitter sozusagen die Hoffnung geäußert wurde, dass ich nicht im Lebensjahr unterbreche. Das kann ich nicht versprechen, weil das muss man vielleicht immer mal wieder dazusagen, Ziel des Chaosradios ist ja, dass man am Anfang der Sendung keine Ahnung haben muss. Also wir fliegen nicht die ganze Zeit tief, aber wir fangen auf jeden Fall auf der Startbahn an. Und deswegen, bevor wir sozusagen sprechen, wie man Dinge nicht kaputtgehen lässt und was eigentlich die Ag Kritis ist, fangen wir am Anfang an und fragen erstmal, wann ist eine Infrastruktur denn kritisch und was mich sozusagen bei der Behandlung dieser Frage auch gleich interessieren würde, ist das denn ein juristischer Begriff, der auch in der Gesetzgebung irgendwie existiert, oder ist das eher sozusagen ein Schlagwort, das man sich jetzt ausgedacht hat?
Das ist eine hervorragende Frage, denn es gibt mehrere Sichtweisen auf die Begriffsbestimmung kritischer Infrastruktur. Fangen wir mal mit der EU an. Es gibt die europäische Direktive EU NIS Directive. Das ist europaweit die Anforderung, dass die Länder jeweils definieren, was ist kritische Infrastruktur und wie schützen sie diese und so weiter. Deutschland hat damals 2015 das AIKIS...
Ich möchte erst mal beim, du wirst gleich lachen, gesunden Menschenverstand anfangen. Wenn ich kritische Infrastruktur höre und man da jetzt drüber spricht, dann stelle ich mir so was vor wie explodierende Kraftwerke, alle Krankenhausbetten klappen gleichzeitig zusammen, weil irgendein Computer gehackt wurde und bringen die Menschen, die drinnen liegen, um, alle Ampeln sind gleichzeitig auf grün. Das wäre jetzt, ohne es erst mal genau zu definieren, kritische Infrastruktur. Ist das die richtige Richtung, die sozusagen das assoziative Bild gibt? Oder reden wir von so was wie, keine Ahnung, Bankencomputer?
Dann fange ich andersrum an. Ich wollte nämlich von oben anfangen, aber dann fangen wir von unten an, wenn du es möchtest. Also es gibt in Deutschland je nach Sichtweise sieben oder neun sogenannte kritische Infrastruktursektoren. Ein Sektor besteht aus unterschiedlichen Branchen, die zusammengeführt wurden als einer. Das eine ist offensichtlich Energie, Sektor Energie, der also Übertragungsnetzbetreiber, welche Tanklager, virtuelle Kraftwerksbetreiber, sogenannte Aggregatoren und so weiter zusammen. Dann haben wir den Sektor Gesundheit, der sowas wie Pharma...
Warte, virtuelle Kraftwerksbetreiber?
Ja, es gibt virtuelle Kraftwerksbetreiber.
Kannst du, ohne die Sendung zu sprengen, das in drei Sätzen erklären, was das ist?
Na du kaufst sozusagen OEM-Strom bei den Produzenten, handelst denen auf einer Stromplattform und gibst dann dem Stromproduzenten den Hinweis, so viel nehme ich dir jetzt ab und verkaufst auf der Plattform, so viel wird jetzt verkauft. Und da man damit ja auch die 50-Hertz-Frequenz aus dem Takt bringen könnte, wenn man jetzt plötzlich ganz viel kauft und gar nicht liefert. Also Strom muss immer Verbrauch gleich Produktion sein. Deswegen musst du dann rauf oder runter fahren, je nachdem wie viel die Menschen konsumieren. Und das müssen die natürlich auch regeln und sicherstellen, weil sonst hast du ein Problem.
Wieder was gelernt. Okay, also Energie, okay.
Genau, also wir haben den Sektor Energie, dann haben wir den Sektor Gesundheit. Da fällt sowas wie Pharma, Krankenhäuser, Labore und so weiter drunter. Dann haben wir den Sektor IT und TK, also Informationstechnologie und Telekommunikation. Da sind natürlich die ganzen Internet, Mobilfunk und so weiter Dienstleister dabei. Dann haben wir den Sektor Transport und Verkehr, also Straße, Schifffahrt, Luftverkehr und so weiter. Dann haben wir den Sektor Wasser, für Frischwassergewinnung und Abwassereinsorgung. Dann haben wir Finanz- und Versicherungswesen. Da kommen eben deine genannten Banken drin vor. Versicherungen, die halt Dinge auszahlen müssen, das Börsengeschäft und so weiter. Dann haben wir die Ernährung, logischerweise, auch irgendwie was grundessentiell ist für die Bevölkerung. Das sind die sieben, ich nenne sie mal Standardsektoren, und das sind auch die sieben, die im BSI-Gesetz geregelt sind. Dann gibt es on top zwei weitere Sektoren, nämlich Staat und Verwaltung, ohne denen natürlich auch nichts los ist. Der ist aber nicht im BSI-Gesetz geregelt, weil das natürlich dann eine untergeordnete Behörde wäre, die dann den Staat regelt. Das geht ja mal nicht. Und Medien und Kultur, und das ist natürlich Ländersache, und damit darf der Bund da nicht so wirklich reinfuschen. Ja, das gesetzliche muss man eben berücksichtigen. Also diese seven of nine, so zu sagen, gibt es.
Warte mal, Energie, Medizin, Transport, Ernährung, Banken, da bin ich schon wieder nicht mitgekommen. Was fehlt da noch?
Also Energie, Gesundheit, IT und TK, Transport und Verkehr, Wasser, Finanz- und Versicherungswesen, Ernährung. Das sind die sieben. Und dann haben wir zusätzlich zu den sieben BSI-Gesetz geregelten, Staat und Verwaltung und Medien und Kultur.
So, das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen komisch, weil das ist ja eigentlich alles. Nein, stopp, halt. In meinem Kopf nennst du diese neuen Begriffe und ich denke so, hm, das ist ja eigentlich alles. Und dann ist meine nächste Frage, das sind ja relativ große Begriffe. Und ich würde denken, nicht alle Teile dieser Infrastruktur sind kritisch. Also vielleicht müssen wir erst mal erklären, was das heißt. Aber um das, was in meinem Kopf ist sozusagen, also meine Güte, der Bankensektor ist kritisch. Darüber könnte man noch mal gesellschaftlich diskutieren. Aber okay, wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so, dass wenn der Geldautomat um die Ecke ausfällt, dass das ein kritisches Versagen der Infrastruktur ist.
Nein, das ist auch nicht. Nee, aber wenn der zentrale Server, der alle Geldautomaten cleart und denen erlaubt, dir das Geld auszuschalten, wenn der wegbrechen und kein Geldautomat mehr funktioniert, bundesweit, nirgendwo mehr, dann hast du binnen ein oder zwei Tagen ein größeres Problem, weil die Menschen anfangen, dann Angst zu haben und sich zu versorgen, wenn sie in ihre Barmittel nicht mehr rankommen, indem sie z.B. looten.
Stopp, kann man diese Grenze festziehen? Also kann man sagen, ist kritische Infrastruktur also immer ein High-Level-Problem?
Ist es so, dass in der Kritisverordnung, das ist eine Verordnung, die an diesem BSI-Gesetz dranhängt, genau reguliert ist, welche Anlagenkategorie kritisch ist und welche nicht. Und ein Geldautomat als Einzelkomponente fällt da nicht runter, weil er keinen Skaleneffekt hat. Und selbst wenn du in ganz Berlin die Hälfte aller Automaten kaputt hast, hast du immer noch die andere Hälfte. Das ist auch nicht kritisch. Was aber kritisch wäre, ist, wenn das Clearing oder das Settlement-System im Hintergrund oder das Autorisierungssystem im Hintergrund ausfällt oder das System zur Aufbereitung eines POS-Terminal-Betreibers, dann hast du das Problem, dass eine zentrale Komponente im Hintergrund ausfällt und damit du einen kritischen Infrastrukturengpass bewirks. Und dann hast du ein Problem. Es geht also immer um die zentralen Kernkomponenten, das Kernbankensystem zum Beispiel, wo du dein Konto gepflegt kriegst. Das ist relevant, nicht die Einzelkomponenten da draußen.
Ist das eine harte Grenze, dass man sozusagen über den Daumen gepeilt sagen kann, wenn es so und so viele Leute gleichzeitig betrifft, ist es kritisch? Oder ist es auch ein Zusammenspiel zwischen Größe und Zeit? Also ich sag mal platt, wenn der Zentralbankenserver für eine Sekunde ausfällt, okay, wenn es ein Tag ist, nee.
Nein, es ist so, dass in der Kritisverordnung geregelt ist, wenn du mehr als 500.000 Menschen oder Personen mit dieser Dienstleistung versorgst, dann bist du kritischer Infrastrukturbetreiber. Das heißt, nicht jedes Autorisierungssystem ist automatisch kritisch, sondern du hast mehr als 500.000 Menschen in der Versorgung. Und das definiert sich auch in dieser Kritisverordnung, weil die Berechnungsformeln zur Ermittlung, du kannst ja nicht sagen, wie stellst du jetzt fest, dass du mehr als 500.000 Leute versorgst, da gehst du ja nicht über, ich habe 500.000 Konten, das machst du spätestens bei Kanalanschlüssen für die Abwasserversorgung nicht, weil du hast nicht 500.000 Personen angeschlossen, sondern Haushalte. Aber du kannst ein Bemessungskriterium benennen, nämlich jetzt, um bei den Banken zu bleiben, Anzahl der Transaktionen im Jahr, die durchschnittlich ein Mensch durchführt. Dann hast du sowas wie, keine Ahnung, 30 Transaktionen im Jahr für, hast du nicht gesehen, Arten und Formen, mal 500.000 macht 15 Millionen. Wenn du also mehr als 15 Millionen Transaktionen in dieser Art und Form mit deinem System machst, dann ist es eben eine Anlage im Sinne der kritischen Infrastrukturen aus diesem BSI-Gesetz und der Kritisverordnung.
Also das heißt aber, für die theoretische Diskussion, wenn man nicht allzu sehr in Detail gehen will, kann man sich jetzt so als Kenngröße vorstellen, diese halbe Million sozusagen. Das ist ja ungewöhnlich handgreiflich. Jetzt sind wir aber auch schon mittendrin im juristischen Begriff. Jetzt seid ihr ja, ich sage mal, aus dem hackerfinen Umfeld, wo ja häufiger mal auch gesagt wird, naja, das, was in Gesetzen steht, ist nicht unbedingt das, wie wir das einschätzen würden. Ist es für euch, wie das definiert wird, zufriedenstellend oder würdet ihr das anders machen?
Ich muss jetzt schreiend aus diesem Raum laufen, oder? Und mit den Händen über den Kopf wehlen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht dachtest du auch, nein, das ist super.
Nein, es ist ein Albtraum aus ganz vielen Sichtweisen. Also du hattest ja gerade schon gesagt, ja, das ist ja so vollständig in meinem Kopf. Und da habe ich ja schon vehement nein gesagt. Also was da zum Beispiel fehlt, ist so was wie die Entsorgung. Wenn wir keine Müllabfuhr haben und keine Entsorgung, dann haben wir ganz schnell so eine Art Pandemie-2. Die Entsorgung ist tatsächlich auch ein Thema, was demnächst auf diese Agenda kommen soll, aber die fehlt. Der Sektor Chemie ist komplett nicht vorhanden. Chemieindustrie und Unfälle sind unkritisch anscheinend für Deutschland. Und Großforschungseinrichtungen und Großforschungsanlagen sind auch ein heikles Thema, wurden aber auch nicht adressiert in Deutschland.
Wenn wir jetzt schon in dieser Diskussion sind, mir fällt gerade auf Medien und Kultur, wenn ich das mit einer halben Million zusammentue, das wirkt ja dann so, als hätten die Lobbyisten für große Medienhäuser das festgelegt, oder ist das da ein bisschen anders geregelt?
Nein, nein, die Medienkultur ist an der Stelle viel weiter und auch enger. Also bezieht sich eher so auf staatliche Einrichtungen, so ein Notfunk oder so ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Radiosender, der in der Krise dann immer noch Dinge erzählen kann. Und das ist auch nicht gesetzlich so schön festgelegt wie in den anderen sieben Sektoren.
Okay, es gibt das Interpretationsspielraum.
Großen. Also ich möchte zu HonkHase noch ganz kurz ergänzen. Ja, sieben Sektoren sind zu wenig, da fehlen welche, das hat er richtig gesagt. Darüber hinaus müssen wir uns aber auch die Grenzwerte anschauen und sie vielleicht auch sektorspezifisch betrachten. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass wir, wenn wir alle Ressourcen, die wir haben, poolen, können wir bei Wasser eine halbe Million abfedern, indem wir LKWs mit Tankwagen fahren lassen. Das haben wir schon mal ausprobiert in einer kleineren Skala. Wir wissen aber auch, dass vielleicht der Grenzwert für ein Krankenhaus bei 30.000 Betten vielleicht noch ein bisschen hoch ist für Betropo-Regionen.
Belegungen.
Genau, Belegungen. 30.000 Betten sind auch nur Belegungen. In meinen Augen muss man sich jeden Sektor einzeln anschauen und sagen, passt das? Können wir das kompensieren? Das ist ja jetzt nicht... Bei diesen Kritischwerwerten geht es ja nicht darum, ist es kritisch oder nicht, sondern haben wir im Rest des Staates genügend Ressourcen, um einen Ausfall einer bestimmten Größeordnung zu kompensieren. Und das ist aber nicht ausreichend erforscht. Da haben wir diese 500.000 nicht aus dem Arsch gezogen und gesagt, die sind jetzt so.
Um das noch zum Abschluss zu bringen und wieder da anzukommen, wo du angefangen hattest, HonkHase, das ist also die deutsche Idee davon, das zu definieren und das gibt es aber auch auf EU-Ebene?
Genau, die Deutschen haben das definiert im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Und die EU hat das sozusagen als Direktive auf europäischer Ebene festgelegt, dass man das landesweit umzusetzen hat, jedes Land für sich. Deutschland ist ja schon relativ weit vorn, die anderen ziehen durchaus auch nach. Und die Amerikaner zum Beispiel haben das vor vielen, vielen Jahren schon definiert. Die haben kritische Infrastrukturen, die haben sogar 16 einzelne Bereiche daraus definiert, aber die haben auch so was wie Wasser und Abwasser getrennt dargestellt. Insofern gibt es auch diese EU-Sicht und man wird sowohl aus EU-Sicht als auch aus deutscher Sicht jetzt eine Anpassung machen, weil die EU-NES wird gerade neu konsultiert. Und in Deutschland sind wir ja gerade am IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 dran. Grad ist ein bisschen nett formuliert seit einiger Zeit dran und es wird noch ein bisschen dauern. Das kommt ein bisschen wie Vapour-Ware, aber lieber ein gutes und ausgereiftes Gesetz als diese kürzlich in den letzten Monaten gruseligen Schnellschussvarianten, die dann einkassiert wurden. Ein gutes Gesetz braucht Zeit und muss reifen.
So, jetzt haben wir das also definiert, was kritische Infrastruktur ist. Jetzt ist ja die spannende Frage für den Chaosradio. Okay, es gibt den Bereich IT und Telekommunikation. Aber andererseits gibt es ja eigentlich nichts mehr, wo nicht Computer drinstecken. These wäre also, egal welchen Sektor du da gesagt hast, da steckt immer und überall auch... Kannst du vielleicht gleich für die Antwort auf meine Frage benutzen. Also meine These wäre, meine Frage ist, ist es so, dass eigentlich in jedem dieser Bereiche genug IT drinsteckt, dass man das immer mitdenken muss und gar nicht ohne kann?
Ja, also ich habe das in dem CHW-Vortrag so beschrieben, dass Informationstechnologie und Kommunikationstechnologie nicht nur der Anhangung 5 der Kritisverordnung ist, sondern auch Betriebsgrundlage für alle anderen Sektoren geworden ist. Also ich stimme mit der These vollständig zu.
Ja, es ist genau so. Ich hätte jetzt, glaube ich, gerne einfach mal ein paar praktische Beispiele. Was kann denn bei oder die anderen, lass es mich anders fragen, ist denn in letzter Zeit mal kritische Infrastruktur auf dieser Art und Weise kaputtgegangen, das sozusagen, wie sie es eigentlich nicht hätte sein dürfen?
Zum Beispiel? Also es kann natürlich sein, dass das kritische, oder andersrum, kritische Infrastrukturbetreiber müssen ja auch IT-Störungen und Ausfälle melden. Und das machen die auch ans BSI. Und da gab es, das müssen nicht immer irgendwelche Hacker oder externe Staaten und schlimme Dinge sein, sondern außergewöhnliche Vorfälle sind zu melden. Und da gab es irgendwie inzwischen eine satte dreistellige Zahl an Meldungen für dieses Jahr beispielsweise. Das kann auch durchaus sein, dass es ein exotischer Problemfall in der IT war, wobei man IT auch immer verbinden muss mit IT und OT. Also es ist nicht nur Informationstechnologie, sondern auch operationelle Technik in den Produktionsanlagen, die da zu berücksichtigen ist.
Du hast sehr viel gesagt, aber die sagen die konkrete Antwort auf meine Frage, geschickt um Shift. Kannst du ein Beispiel sagen?
Also wenn das Kernbankensystem ausfällt und kein Geld mehr abgehoben werden kann und keine Überweisung mehr geht oder was jetzt, ich überlege gerade heute, gestern, ich glaube es war sogar heute, Target 2 ist ein Swift-System, eine Funktionalität, um über dieses Swift-Netzwerk Interbankenexchange zu machen, länderübergreifend.
Da gibt es ein eigenes Chaosradio zu, kann ich sehr empfehlen, schreiben wir die Shownotes.
Ok, perfekt. Und dieses System, Target 2, hatte jetzt wieder einen Aussetzer und konnte man also nicht benutzen. Sprich, das war definitiv ein Problem und ein Outage.
Und jetzt muss ich nochmal zurückgehen und fragen, in dem Gesetz steht also, das darf eigentlich nicht passieren?
Es soll nicht passieren.
Was passiert, wenn es doch passiert, werden dann die Betreiber, denen das passiert, verknackt? Oder sagt das Gesetz, damit das nicht passiert, muss folgendes gewährleistet sein?
Also zum einen soll es natürlich idealerweise nicht passieren, deswegen sagt das Gesetz ja auch, du sollst diese Schutzmaßnahmen einführen. Also genau genommen, das ist jetzt BSI-Gesetz Paragraph 8a, du sollst einen angemessenen, branchen-spezifischen Stand der Technik umsetzen, damit deine IT eben keine Outage hat. Falls du das, warum auch immer, verkackt hast, nach Paragraph 8b machst du eine Meldung ans BSI und nach Paragraph 14 gibt es Bußgeldvorschriften und das wird alles als Ordnungswidrigkeit gehandhabt. Sprich, wenn du dich nicht sauber registriert hast beim BSI, die Meldung nicht absetzt, dich nicht um den Nachweis gekümmert hat, alle zwei Jahre musst du einen Nachweis erbringen, dass du das quasi umgesetzt hast durch Prüfer, dann kann es sein, dass man dir eine Geldbuße für 50.000 Euro ausspricht.
Jetzt ist das Bankending gleichzeitig auch noch, naja obwohl, ich frage mich, also das fällt aus, na geht es nicht, aber zumindest in meinem Kopf könnte man das Bankenwesen auch noch auf Papier und mit Kassenbüchern machen. Das würde dann alles sehr lange dauern, aber zumindest theoretisch ginge es. Es gibt jetzt so andere Sachen, wo ich mich frage, also ich entschuldige mich für das Klischeebeispiel, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, ein Kernkraftwerk von Hand zu fahren, also quasi da fallen alle Computer aus, Kernkraftwerk von Hand fahren, vielleicht stimmt das auch gar nicht, ist eher schwierig.
Doch, das ist tatsächlich so und um es nicht zu abstrakt und komplex zu machen, ist es sogar noch einfacher bei einem Wasserwerk. Bei einem Wasserwerk hast du fast immer, nicht bei allen, aber fast immer den manuellen Fallback. Das heißt, du betreibst deinen Wasserwerk mit IT und mit OT und wenn du die komplette IT abgeraucht hast, die wird geransomiert, die ist runtergebrannt, whatever, hast du halt einfach noch ganz gepflegt deine manuellen mechanischen Prozesse. Sprich, du sagst deinen Mitarbeitern in der Verwaltung, wenn es Puff macht, dann gehst du hier hin und machst folgende Handbewegung. Und das bringst du denen dann bei und wenn es eine Outage gibt, dann gehen die halt hin und machen manuellen Weiterbetrieb.
Also wir reden aber tatsächlich zu sagen von Weiterbetrieb, nicht von Notabschaltung.
Genau, das Ziel und Sinn und Zweck einer kritischen Infrastruktur ist ja, diese immer aufrechtzuerhalten, die Versorgung. Und zwar die Versorgung mit der sogenannten kritischen Dienstleistung. Die KDL, die kritische Dienstleistung, ist ja das, was die Bevölkerung braucht, um im gemeinsamen Wesen zu leben. Sprich, du brauchst Essen, du brauchst Trinken, du brauchst Abwasserentsorgung, du brauchst Energie. Und genau das ist zu schützen. Sprich, wenn du also dafür sorgen kannst, dass du mit diesem manuellen und mechanischen Betrieb die Produktion aufrecht hältst, alles gut. Das ist der Fallback.
Was mir gerade auch auffällt, ist, wenn wir über kritische Infrastruktur reden, dann reden wir immer bei Dinge, die erst durch längeres Ausbleiben Schaden anrichten. Das ist gar nicht sozusagen das Klassische, da explodieren irgendwo Sachen oder zählt es auch dazu.
Also kann auch dazu zählen, wobei Explosionen, die müsste ja durch einen IT-Störungen bewirkt werden. Das Gesetz, dieses BSI-Gesetz, kritische Infrastruktur, adressiert ausschließlich einen Versorgungsengpass oder Versorgungsausfall dieser kritischen Dienstleistung bedingt durch IT-Störungen.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Ich dachte jetzt seit dem Anfang der Sendung, dass es bei kritischer Infrastruktur erst mal generell um kritische Infrastruktur geht, aber es geht schon ganz explizit um die IT-Bestandteile von kritischer Infrastruktur.
Also das ist ja das, was ich anfangs auch meinte mit unterschiedlichen Sichtweisen. Wenn du nämlich jetzt das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz in der Katastrophenhilfe fragst, werden die sagen, na Chemie ist sowas von kritisch. Das kannst du dir gar nicht vorstellen für uns. Und wenn wir eine Großschadenslage haben oder einen Gefahrguttransport, der in die Hose gegangen ist, dann ist das für die auch kritisch aus Bevölkerungsschutzsicht oder auch THW oder wer auch immer da loshüpft. Das ist aber nicht ein IT-bedingter Vorfall. Und das ist halt das, was man sozusagen als Cyber-Cyber im § 8a BSI-Gesetz abgedeckt hat.
Jetzt hast du gerade erklärt, es gibt sozusagen bei vielen Dingen, und anscheinend, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, auch bei Kernkraftwerken den Handhebel, oder wahrscheinlich zwei oder drei. Aber gibt es denn auch in diesen kritischen Infrastrukturen Dinge, wo, wenn die Technik weg ist, dann ist das Ding am Arsch, um Ijon zu zitieren?
Ja, und es gibt auch Dinge, die am Arsch sind, wenn die Technik nicht da ist, weil du dann halt einen Versorgungsengpass hast. Ich gebe dir ein banales Beispiel, Flugabfertigung. Du hast irgendwie deine Flugzeuge, die damals vor dieser Pandemie, man erinnert sich vielleicht noch, diese großen Vögel aus Metall, die durch die Lüfte... Ja, genau. Das war ja so, dass die in einer kurzen Taktrate ans Gate gedockt sind, alle mal raus, einmal durchfegen, alle mal rein, zack in die Luft, weil die Philosophie ist ja in dieser Branche, ein Flieger verdient Geld in der Luft, nicht auf dem Boden. Deswegen ist die Turnaround-Zeit immer kritisch, möglichst schnell die Kiste wieder hochkriegen. Wenn du einen Totalausfall deiner zentralen Infrastruktur hast, kannst du aber nicht sagen, oh well, steig mal alles ein, wird schon passen. Du musst ja auch gesetzliche Vorgaben einhalten, wer steigt ein. Es darf kein Gepäck ohne den zugehörigen Besitzer fliegen. Wenn der Besitzer nicht antritt, musst du das Gepäck wieder rausholen.
Ich wünsch, es wäre umgedreht auch so.
Wenn deine zentrale Infrastruktur dieses Check-Ins flöten ist, dann fangen die auch an, die Papierprozesse rauszupulen. Nur du hast da einen Chaos an den Flughäfen, kaskadiert. Bei einem macht es richtig puff und dann auf einmal sind überall Verzögerungen. Du hast dann halt ausgefallene Flüge, verspätete Flüge. Du hast einen Delay über den ganzen Tag, manchmal über mehrere Tage. Das heißt, ein Ausfall dieser Infrastrukturkomponenten oder Teile, also diese Anlagenkategorien, führt dazu, dass du einen Engpass hast und damit auch nicht mehr diesen digitalisierten, automatisierten Durchsatz erfüllen kannst. Sprich Cyber, Cyber oder Digitalisierung führt dazu, dass du mehr Versorgung für mehr Menschen bereitstellen kannst. Und das leidet dann durchaus mal unter einem Ausfall.
Ich muss jetzt doch nochmal was Grundsätzliches fragen. Und zwar, wenn ich, es gibt ja diese assoziative Bauchbild von der kritischen Infrastruktur. Und da denke ich ja zum Beispiel, ich fände es schon kritisch, wenn es im Supermarkt nichts mehr gäbe. Also da kann ich mir sozusagen, da hat ein bekannter mal gesagt, der Firmness der Zivilisation wurde da sehr schnell dünn, wenn es so eine Woche lang einfach nichts mehr gäbe. Es ist aber nicht so kritisch, ob ich in den Urlaub fliegen kann oder nicht. Und es ist eigentlich auch nicht kritisch im Sinne von lebensbedrohlich, ob jetzt Fluggesellschaften Fettkohle machen oder nicht. Und ich würde halt denken, wenn man jetzt sozusagen Warnwirtschaft und so was anguckt, dass man den Flughafen vielleicht auch von Hand betreiben würde, um die wichtigen Güter zu betreiben. Und das aber auch nicht so schlimm ist, wenn man... So, das ist halt das Bild in meinem Kopf. Und von dem, was ihr erzählt habt, ist es aber dasselbe. Also ob es ausfällt, dass alle Leute in den Urlaub fliegen kann, ist laut dieses Gesetzes, laut der Idee dasselbe, wie die Supermärkte können nicht mehr versorgt werden. Oder gibt es da noch Abstufungen?
Nein, gibt es nicht. Aber man unterschlägt gerne, ja gut, Ferienflieger, who cares. Aber es gibt ja auch Frachtabfertigungssysteme. Und Fracht kann zum Beispiel auch in so einer Pandemie bedeuten, Schutzkleidung und Schutzkomponenten. Wenn du die halt nicht transportieren kannst, ist doof.
Genau, das sehe ich ein und das meinte ich gerade mit. Ich würde unterstellen, dass man sozusagen ohne IT vielleicht die wichtige Fracht noch bewegt kriegt, aber halt nicht alle Leute in den Urlaub fliegen kann. Und das wäre halt nicht so schlimm, wie gar nichts geht mehr.
Nee, der Markt hat sich daher angepasst an der Stelle. Du hast halt die erwartenden gewissen Turneraumtieren über die Lebenszeit von so einem Flugzeug. Dann wird der Flugplan entsprechend geplant. Und wenn du dann von heute auf morgen die Flüge um die Hälfte reduzieren musst, weil die Turneraumtime so groß geworden ist, weil alles auf Papier passieren müsste in dem Fall dann, dann hast du die Maschine aber nicht da, wo du sie brauchst. Und dann kriegst du sie auch nicht dahin, wo du sie brauchst. Ich habe mal ein Jahr für die Air Berlin damals noch Social Media Teamlead gemacht, On Duty, so im Schichtsystem. Und das war mega sichtbar und spannend, dass du wirklich einen Sturm in hohen Luftschichten, so er hat 48 Stunden später Ripple-Effekte im ganzen Netzwerk gehabt. Weil irgendwie eine Connection mit 20 Flügen an dem Tag auf dem Hinweg eine halbe Stunde länger braucht als ein Rückweg. Und dafür war auf dem Rückweg eine halbe Stunde schneller ist. Und das reicht schon, dass du 48 Stunden später massivste Verspätungen am anderen Ende von Europa hast. Und zwar mit einem direkten Kausalen zusammen machen.
Ich möchte die Frage noch mal auf einer höheren Ebene stellen, und fragen, dieses Gesetz zum Schutz der kritischen Infrastruktur und der IT darin, zielt es darauf ab, dass wir als Menschen überleben, oder zieht es auch darauf ab, dass Firmen genug Geld verdienen können? Oder ist die implizite Annahme dahinter, dass beides dasselbe ist?
Nein, also es zielt nicht darauf ab, dass Firmen Geld verdienen können, sondern dass die kritischen Dienstleistungen, oder eine Vermeidung der Begrifflichkeit Vermeidung von Versorgungsausfall oder Engpass dieser kritischen Dienstleistungen für die Gesamtbevölkerung in Deutschland sozusagen gewährleistet wird. Und das Angemessen, was ich vorhin meinte, bei angemessenen branchen spezifischer Stand der Technik, das Angemessen ist sozusagen der Punkt, an dem vielleicht ein bisschen Wirtschaft berücksichtigt wird, nämlich in dem Verhältnis, du kannst jetzt keine Ahnung, 10 Millionen investieren, um eine Superschutzmaßnahme zu implementieren, aber du bist halt ein kleines Wasserwerk oder ein kleiner Flughafen, der gerade eben über der 500.000 Grenze ist. Und wenn du die 10 Millionen investieren würdest, dann bist du halt insolvent, weil du keine Kohle mehr hast. Jetzt kann man sagen, wir zwingen dich das zu machen, weil du jede Schutzmaßnahme implementieren musst, aber das danach pleite. Und was bedeutet das in der Konsequenz? Du hast einen 100% Versorgungsausfall. Das wäre also nicht angemessen, wenn diese kleine Bude diese 10 Millionen investiert. Wenn aber ein Konzern um die Ecke kommt, der viele Milliarden am Start hat und dann sagt, die 10 Millionen habe ich nicht investiert, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist total hoch, dass das bei uns passieren kann, das wäre dann wiederum nicht angemessen. Dieser Handlungsspielraum, Breite gibt es, aber es ist nicht so, dass dieses Gesetz besonders auf Wirtschaft optimiert ist, sondern wirklich auf welche Dinge sind Abläufe im regulären Leben der Bevölkerung, die essenziell sind und wovon die Bevölkerung einfach auch abhängt, dass die reibungslos funktionieren.
Okay, dann haben wir bis zu dieser Stelle schon mal eingekreist, was das eigentlich ist und was es können soll. Und ich würde dann gleich, glaube ich, zu der Frage zurückkommen, wie man das kaputt machen könnte und was die Gefahren sind, bevor das passiert. Hören wir aber eine kleine Musik, die zumindest namentlich auch zum Thema passt, Defect Compiler von Health Star. Chaosradio 263, wir sprechen über kritische Infrastruktur, die wir jetzt schon definiert haben bzw. uns angehört haben, wie man die definieren kann und warum das alles wichtig ist. Und jetzt möchte ich gerne wissen, was da kaputt gehen kann. Jetzt ist es ja so und da werden wir nicht ganz von vorne anfangen. Wir sprechen hier im Chaosradio sehr viel darüber, wie man IT-Systeme kaputt machen kann, zerforschen kann heißt das Fachwort. All das kann man natürlich, wahrscheinlich auch mit IT-Systemen von kritischer Infrastruktur machen. Und deswegen würde ich es vielleicht verengen wollen auf, was sind in eurer Meinung nach Dinge, die realistisch gefährlich sind jetzt gerade bei kritischen Infrastrukturen. Entweder, weil es halt sozusagen Angriffspunkte sind, die sehr gut funktionieren, oder weil es vielleicht Dinge sind, die vernachlässigt werden und deswegen besonders schwierig sind.
Also ich habe ja ein Lieblingsproblem bei der Beratung und Auditierung von kritischen Infrastrukturen. Das habe ich sogar mal bei einem Vortrag für, jetzt mal überlegen, wo habe ich den gehalten, beim dritten DIVOC Push to Talk für den CCC, genau. Und zwar habe ich sogar eine neue Berufsgruppe dafür ins Leben gerufen und definiert, das ist die Fernwartungsarchäologen. Weil da hatte ich auch in dem Vortrag, hatte ich so ein bisschen erzählt über die Erlebnisse eines Kritis-Prüfers, was sind so die Epic Fails, die es gibt. Und diesen C3 DIVOC PPT Vortrag, den gibt es auch frei im Netz auf media.ccc.de.
Show notes.
Genau. Und ich habe dann auch angefangen so mit diesem, beim Wort Fernwartung leide ich innerlich immer ein bisschen. Und zwar weil du echt jeden, jeden, und ich meine damit wirklich jeden zerforschten oder zerraffelten, schwachsinnigsten Weg in die Infrastruktur von kritischen Infrastruktur-Dienstleistern findest. Das ist so abartig kaputt manchmal, weil es einfach, ja, damals TM aufgesetzt wurde, nie wieder angefasst wurde, irgendwelche Ingenieursbüros, die wirklich sehr kompetent die Verfügbarkeit in der Produktion sicherstellen und tolle Bauteile machen. Aber die haben dann irgendwann so ein VNC oder PC-Anywhere 2.0 auf ein Windows 3.11 installiert und das läuft heute noch. Ja, du lachst, das ist Fernwartungsarchäologie. Ich hab nicht gelogen.
Nur kurz um das zu erklären. VNC und PC-Anywhere, das sind Softwareprodukte zur Rechnerfernbedienung, die, ich sag's mal ganz diplomatisch, in die Jahre gekommen sind. Und die so ein bisschen, also ich glaube, das Beispiel, das ich wählen würde, ist, ein Brief gilt ja als sicher, qua gesellschaftlichen Vertrag, dass man den nicht aufmacht. Wenn man aber Dinge wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, wirklich geheim halten will, würde man sie nicht in einen Papierumschlag packen.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Das, was ich da erlebe, ist die Postkarte.
Das ist noch schlimmer.
Also das ist wirklich ein Weg rein in die Infrastruktur. Ganz, ganz übel und fies. Und viele neigen auch dazu, nicht ihre Produktionsumgebungen, so wie man es eigentlich machen sollte, entweder komplett per Air Gap abzuschotten oder zu sagen, ich habe hier auch einen sauberen, getrennten Firewall-Weg. Sondern eher so, da steht irgendwie so eine Firewall dazwischen und die lässt viel durch und dann passt das schon.
Aber ich wollte das mal da wirklich gerade grundsätzlich fragen. Weil, also genau, die eine Sache, die ich ja hier gelernt habe am Chaosradio ist, wenn es ein IT-System ist, dann kann es auch kaputt gehen. Und die Chancen, dass man das absichtlich kaputt gehen lassen kann, sind auch relativ hoch. Da wäre für mich die logische Konsequenz, also wenn ich kritische Infrastruktur habe, dann möchte ich genau diese Air Gap, was so gesagt dazu bedeutet ja, es gibt keinerlei Verbindung zum Netz, sondern wenn ich ein System ran will, dann muss ich hinfahren. Ist das nicht eigentlich das, was man dann überall machen sollte? Oder ist es dann wieder umgekehrt wieder so, dass man sagt, aber weil es eben kritische Infrastruktur ist, gibt es eben auch Szenarien, wo du halt schnell da rankommen musst, und dann gar nicht die Zeit ist, hinzufahren?
Exakt dies, meine Antwort wäre nämlich ja-in. Also was du bei einem Kernkraftwerk machst, ist, nein, du kannst nicht aus dem Internet die Brennstäbe rauf runterfahren. Ja, völliger Humbug. So, du kommst schon vielleicht in die Produktion noch, aber um das wirklich rauf runterzufahren. In einem Kraftwerk gibt es ja auch ganz nebenbei noch Safety-Funktionalität und Safety-Schnellabschaltungen. In jedem, wirklich in jedem Kraftwerk ist eine Funktionalität von. Wenn diese und diese Regelungen so sind, dann ist das irgendwie komisch. Und es gibt so eine Art Null-Linie. Wenn du mit dieser Parametrisierung und Verknüpfung bei der Null-Linie landest, schaltet das Kraftwerk automatisch ab. Und die Schnellabschaltung ist ein bis drei Sekunden. Also wirklich schnell abgeschaltet. Und du kannst da noch nicht mal als Mensch gegensteuern, wenn du der Meinung bist, warte mal, das ist falsch. Ich mach hier mal kurz die Pumpe an. Dann guckt das Ding intern. In diesem Zustand darf diese Pumpe angehen. Nein, es gibt Voraussetzungen, die sagen, äh, äh. Und dann kannst du da so viel rumschalten, wie du willst. Die Pumpe geht nicht an. Weil die internen Kontrollsysteme für Safety, also zum Schutz der Menschen, sagen, Alter, du liegst so falsch, wir sind 100% sicher, dass du falsch liegst. Nein, die Voraussetzungen sind nicht erfüllt. Erfüll die Voraussetzungen, dann darfst du diese Pumpe auch abschalten, dann sagen wir nicht nein. Und diese Dinge werden dann gerne mal vergessen, wenn jemand sagt, boah, ich hab hier irgendein Skada-Light-System im Internet gesehen und kann schlimme Dinge tun. Die Frage ist, welche Safety-Maßnahmen und Hintergrund-Funktionalitäten noch da sind und ob man wirklich bis zum Ziel durchkommt. Und wenn das tatsächlich so einfach wäre, dann hätten wir deutlich mehr Outages weltweit, die richtig heftig sind. Also das muss ich ein bisschen relativieren. Trotz allem ist es so, dass kritische Infrastruktur natürlich mit noch mehr Fortschreitender Digitalisierung, Globalisierung, IP-Iffizierung, wie ich es immer nenne, irgendwann zerforscht oder zerraffelt werden, weil wir dann so Erlebnisse haben wie in Düsseldorfer Uniklinikum, dass die sich dann zwei Wochen von der Notaufnahme abschalten müssen, weil ein Remote-Access-System halt Buggy war bis zum Access und die Hersteller dann nicht ordentlich die Patches zeitnah bereitgestellt haben, dafür aber der Angriff total easy war und dann kommen Angreifer eben da drüber rein und dann ist das halt kaputt und du kannst eine Uniklinik nicht ohne Weiteres komplett ohne Netz fahren. Das funktioniert ja auch nicht ganz, weil du musst dich ja an die Versorgungsleit stellen, an die Dispatcher und so weiter anpacken und sagen, hier, ich habe noch Betten frei für folgendes Problem. So ganz ohne Internet geht es nicht. Die Frage ist nur, bis wie viele kritische Kernkomponenten kommt dieses Internet durch und wie einfach?
Aber das heißt, ich fasse mal zusammen, also eigentlich will man kritische Infrastruktur nicht am Netz haben und deswegen, wenn das eine Möglichkeit ist, macht man das und wenn das keine Möglichkeit ist, dann ist man wieder bei diesem Punkt, dann muss das aber auch state of the art sein und dann auch nur mit exakt der Funktionalität, die man unbedingt braucht und nicht mehr.
Naja, so wie man das in einem Sicherheitskonzept machen würde, wenn man ein Sicherheitskonzept macht. Minimal Prinzip, so.
Ja, ich wollte es ja noch nicht einmal so sagen. Die umgekehrte Frage ist, ist kritische Infrastruktur einen Lohn oder wird das mehr angegriffen als andere IT-Systeme oder ist es da auch eher so Gelegenheit macht diebe und wenn die nicht da ist, da gibt es ja jetzt niemand wirklich besonders Mühe.
Also aus der beruflichen Situation bei High Solutions haben wir auch so eine Hotline und eine Incident-Response, First-Response und so. Wir sehen ja schon seit Jahren, dass es immer mehr wird. Die Corona-Pandemie war so ein Brennglas. Das hat es dieses Jahr also nochmal, das steigt sowieso, aber jetzt ist es nochmal deutlich schneller gestiegen. Weil sich eben auch die Angreifer natürlich im Homeoffice befinden und Realisiert haben, dass man viel Geld mit Cyber-Cyber machen kann. Ich glaube 2007 war der Break-Even, wo du mehr Geld mit Cyber-Crime als organisierte Kriminalität gemacht hast, als mit Drogenhandel. Also schon lange ist ein altes Thema und die Unterabteilung Ransomware hat natürlich gerade einen mega Aufschwung, weil die sich über Jahre hinweg optimiert hat in Richtung, wie ziehen wir den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche?
Also Ransomware, nur um es kurz zu erklären, auf verschiedenen Wegen wird eine Software auf deinen Rechner aufgebracht, die wesentliche Komponenten des Rechners verschüsselt und der Deal, ob der dann durchgeführt wird oder nicht, heißt, zahle uns auf diesem obskuren Weg so und so viel Geld, dann schalten wir den Rechner wieder frei, wenn nicht, löschen wir alles. Und wenn das sozusagen auf einer kritischen Infrastruktur aufschlägt, ist natürlich doppelt doof.
Ja, wobei das aber auch tatsächlich bei nicht kritischer Infrastruktur oft passiert. Das ist eben der wichtige Punkt. Die suchen sich eben lohnenswerte Ziele, die zahlen werden. Das sind jetzt bei kritischen Infrastrukturen vorzugsweise Krankenhäuser. Wenn du die verschlüsselst, ist doof. Und die haben es dringend. Das heißt, die zahlen eher mal. Aber was auch gute Ziele sind, sind Universitäten, staatliche oder städtische Kommunalsysteme, aber eben auch Produktionsumgebung von soliden Mittelständlern. Weil die haben Kohle, die haben durchaus ein paar Hunderttausend bis Millionen. Und das ist dann so was wie, mein Opa hat den Laden gegründet, mein Vater weitergetrieben und ich hab jetzt alles gemacht. Ich stehe mit dem Rücken zur Wand und hab nichts mehr und ich hab hier jede einzelne Familie, die bei mir arbeitet, kenn ich. Da hat schon der Vater hier gearbeitet. Und der hat dann die Chance, ja, ich renn vor die Wand, werd insolvent oder bin Bankrott oder ich zahle. Also die erpressen schon Leute, die wirklich den Druck haben.
Ich hab alles gemacht außer IT-Sicherheit und damit würde ich tatsächlich sagen, in das nächste Thema gehen wollen. Weil, also mein vielleicht leicht zynischer Blick auf die Gesellschaft ist ja der. Es gibt Menschen, die in unserem System Geld verdienen und die werden mehr oder weniger vom Gesetz reguliert. Also nicht alle in möglichen Hinsichten. Also was Sicherheitsanforderungen an die Produkte, die sie verkaufen, Steuern, die sie zahlen sollen. Also es gibt so ein Gesellschaftsvertrag, der durch Gesetze ausformuliert wird, was denn eigentlich Leute machen sollen. Was dann passiert ist, dass diese Gesetze in der, ich sag mal für die Gesellschaft schlechtestmöglichen Lesweise interpretiert werden, dass man eben keine Steuer zahlt, dass man die Sicherheitsvorschriften nur so weit erfüllt, wie es unbedingt ist, damit die Produktionskosten nicht steigern und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, mein Verdacht wäre jetzt, wenn es so etwas wie das Gesetz der kritischen IT-Infrastruktur gibt, dass, wo drin steht, also ihr müsstet eigentlich schon mal gucken, dass das alles funktioniert, dass, ich bin mal ein bisschen despektierlich, dass dann wie bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung ist, man bestellt also einen Datenschutzbeauftragten, der hat in einem sechs Wochen Kurs dieses Label sich erarbeitet, hat eine Lizenz und dann hat man vielleicht so einen Kritisbeauftragten, der hat eine Lizenz und sagt, ja, da hab ich mir das mal angeguckt, das glänzt ja schon ganz schön, das ist bestimmt sicher. Also mit anderen Worten mein Verdacht wäre, da wird zu wenig getan, damit die kritische Infrastruktur wirklich sicher ist, eben weil das Geld kosten würde. Wie ist es denn wirklich?
Also zur Hälfte ist es so. Die andere Hälfte ist, dass du so viele Gesetze, Vorgaben, Regulatorien und Dinge an der Backe hast, dass du auch irgendwann nicht mehr durchblickst bei einer kritischen Infrastruktur. Na ja, ganz ehrlich, du zu Hause, überleg dir mal, wie viel Giraffel habe ich eigentlich zu Hause? Ein Receiver, der am Netz ist, ein Smart TV, mehrere Handys für alle Leute, die hier wohnen. Ich habe einen weißen Kuckuck-Router, der dann noch WLAN macht, ein Gäste-WLAN. Ich habe irgendwelche Smart-Home-Komponenten, irgendwelche Leuchtmittel, die ich per App steuern kann, irgendeine doofe Heizungsregulierung über Cloud. Ich habe irgendeinen Ringdienst von Amazon an meiner Türklingel. Also allein schon zu Hause, ich habe ein NAS, irgendeine Storage Box. Allein zu Hause, wenn du nicht nur die Rechner nimmst, hast du schon total viel IP-Geraffel. Und jetzt überlegst du mal, du bist eine kritische Infrastruktur und hast echt viel IP-Geraffel. Und dann gehst du dann noch hin und sagst, und das Zeug läuft seit 10, 20, 30, 40 Jahren und wird noch 10, 20, 30, 40 Jahre laufen. Genau. Die Mitarbeiter sind nicht mehr da. Du hast also eine Historie, die du nicht so ohne weiteres durchblickst oder mal eben abschneiden kannst und sagst, ey, der Hersteller ist insolvent gegangen und den gibt es gar nicht mehr. Ja, dann reißen wir mal die Baugruppe raus und stecken eine neue rein, würde heißen, du musst die Produktion stoppen, die Baugruppe austauschen und dann wieder in Betrieb nehmen, musst aber auch dann die ganzen Safety-Vorschriften, Regularien, weißt ja, guck, guck, was darauf, feintunen, du hättest Wochen oder Monate eines Ausfalls. Wenn du jetzt, also wenn du einen Kernspintomographen einer Uniklinik nimmst, da läuft meistens so was wie ein Winos 98 drauf. Warum? Weil der Hersteller dazu ausliefert, das ist mal zertifiziert worden und damit erfüllst du die medizinischen Vorgaben für Komponenten im oder am menschlichen Körper, Punkt.
Aber warte mal, du hast jetzt die ganze Zeit immer gesagt, was nicht gemacht wird, was wird denn gemacht und wer macht überhaupt irgendwas?
Na was gemacht wird, kritische Infrastruktur-Dienstleister oder Betreiber machen auch sehr oft IT-Sicherheit und viele wissen auch, was ihr Problem ist. Es gibt auch wirklich viele, die das echt ordentlich machen, weil du zum Beispiel dann merkst, dass noch nie, wenn du den Wasser aufdrehst, kein Wasser rauskommt. Es läuft einfach. Was da im Hintergrund passiert, ist erstmal aus IT-Security-Cyber-Cybersicht-Hupe wichtig ist, Wasser muss fließen. Ob da die neueste Jamba-Wamba-Patch-Version von irgendeinem Netzwerkrouter drauf ist, ja ey, geschenkt. So, ne? Aus der Versorgungssicherheit ist das völlig egal. Du musst dich erstellen, dass Wasser läuft, wenn jemand einen Hahn aufdreht. Und ja, dann hast du manchmal Sicherheitsdefizite, aber wenn du halt an irgendeinem Punkt sagst, die Maßnahmen drumherum und das Risiko passt nicht mehr im Verhältnis, dann macht's auch irgendwann Puff. Klar, kommt da Ransomware vorbei oder wer auch immer. Und an der Stelle ist es oft auch so, muss man sagen, die einen, die alles tun, die anderen, die nix tun und dazwischen gibt's wie immer auch die ganze Bandbreite, die dann sagen, ja, die Mitarbeiter sind zwar nicht mehr da, so wie Ijon sagte, die das eigentlich aufgesetzt haben, aber die Leute, die da sind, die wissen ziemlich genau, wo die Defizite sind. Wir sind aber zu wenig Leute, wir haben kein Geld und keine weiteren Stellen. So, und dann wird's eng.
Aber das ist doch keine Lösung. Also ich meine, klar ist es vielleicht so, aber das ist doch keine Lösung.
Das ist keine Lösung, das ist das Problem. Und jetzt dein gesellschaftlicher Vertrag, da hätte ich auch noch eine Anmerkung zu. Meiner Meinung nach gibt's noch ein kaputtes Konstrukt in diesem Vertrag. Wir haben nämlich in der Bildungspolitik seit Jahrzehnten versagt und ich sage damit wirklich voll versagt, Cyber-Cyber, also IT-Security als auch Medienkompetenz in die Bildungspolitik reinzubringen. Wenn wir Stand heute, kannst du immer noch Informatik studieren, ohne einmal irgendwas mit Sicherheit zu tun gehabt zu haben. Also selbst wenn du studierst die Fachrichtung, kannst du es immer noch ohne schaffen. Was uns fehlt ist Medienkompetenz und IT-Sicherheitskompetenz in der Bildungspolitik. Und wenn du das heute implementierst, wirst du die Auswirkungen erst in 10, 20, 30 Jahren spüren. Und wir labern immer noch darüber, ob irgendwelche Zugriffe für die Länder bereitgestellt werden. Ihr gesamter Markt hat so wenig Leute, die Ahnung haben.
Okay, aber das Bildungsproblem, das kriegen wir heute nicht mehr geklärt. Nein, aber das ist ein Defizit. Wir können heute nicht den Kapitalismus anzünden. Wir kriegen heute nicht das Bildungsproblem geklärt. Wir sollen sozusagen beim Thema bleiben, bei der kritischen IT-Infrastruktur bzw. bei den IT-Komponenten der kritischen Infrastruktur. So, wer sind die Akteure, die was genau besser machen können, abgesehen davon, dass wir ins Startrek-Otopia einziehen?
Ijon, mach mal. Also, es gibt große Mengen der Infrastruktur, der kritische Infrastruktur, sind Privatwirtschaft, die da die Vorschriften einhalten müssen. Das, was staatlich ist, ist meist kommunal und selten Länderaufgabe. Und dass Kritiksthemen tatsächlich sowohl planerisch wie auch irgendwie im Doing dann auf Bundesebene stattfinden, ist unglaublich selten, dass das passiert. Mir fällt tatsächlich kein konkretes Beispiel ein von einer Infrastruktur, die auf Bundesebene betrieben wird, politisch. Sondern das ist alles dann Länder oder Kommunen. HonkHase, oder? Übersehe ich was? Passt.
Aber ich habe ja gleich eine Nachfrage. Wie sinnvoll ist das denn, dass das sozusagen bei den Kommunen liegt? Weil gerade IT-Systeme sind ja meinem gefährlichen Halbwissen nach eher standardisierbar. Beim Bildung ist ja Ländersache, das ist auch so eine schöne Diskussion. Da kann man auch sagen, es gibt regionale Unterschiede, meinetwegen. Aber ist das denn bei IT sinnvoll, dass das bei den Kommunen liegt?
Das ist ja in dem Fall nicht IT, das ist ja Infrastruktur, die auch von IT gesteuert werden könnte. Im Regelfall wird gesteuert. Das sind ja Stadtwerke am Ende des Tages. Du kannst jetzt ja nicht sagen, die Stadtwerke bei mir im Wohnort machen wir jetzt zu, wir bündeln das, fusionieren das und machen pro Land eins. Das geht ja schon mal nicht. Dafür liegen die Kabel und die Rohre und die Ventile nicht und die Pipelines. Deswegen musst du das schon dann auf der kommunalen Ebene machen.
Das war nicht das, was ich sagen wollte, weil das finde ich sehr, sehr einsichtig. Aber der Punkt ist, es gibt doch nur endlich viele IT-Komponenten für Wasser-Stadtwerke und wäre es da nicht sozusagen sinnvoll, eben weil das dann eher standardisiert wird, dass das auf einer höheren Ebene verhandelt wird?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden, wie standardisiert. Und es gibt nur eine endliche Menge Komponenten. Also noch mal, jede kritische Infrastruktur, die du da hast, jeder Betreiber existiert seit gefühlt Ewigkeiten. Und die Historie ist so gewachsen, wie sie gewachsen ist. Du glaubst doch nicht, dass da echt alles immer total standardisiert ist und ein Stadtwerk wie das andere aussieht.
Noch nicht. Aber meine Frage wäre gewesen, ob es nicht sinnvoll wäre, ab jetzt an einer sozusagen zentralisierten Struktur zu arbeiten.
Möchtest du also überall zentral Microsoft Windows einführen für immer, bei allen, als monolithisches Konstrukt? Also von der Heterogenität hast du ja auch eine Varianz bei Risiken und Ausfällen, denk dran. Du möchtest nicht unbedingt alle nach idealem Standard aufgebaut haben, weil wenn ein Problem existiert und es kaskadiert, dann hast du eine Großschadenslage, jetzt kommen wir langsam in die Richtung, was macht eigentlich die Ag Kritis, Cyberhilfswerk. Sowas willst du ja eigentlich nicht. Dass eine Baugruppe überall eingesetzt wird.
Da würde ich sozusagen politisch dagegen argumentieren und fragen wollen, wenn jede Kommune selbst entscheidet, wie sie die kritischen IT-Bestandteile in der Infrastruktur schützt, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Microsoft ankommt und sagt so, hey Leute, guck mal, wir haben hier diesen voll geilen Microsoft Windows 98 Wasserkraft Stadtwerk, a Pumple. Und wenn ihr den einbaut, dann zahlen, den geben wir noch zwei Computer für das PC-Kabinett an eurer Schule.
Genau, also nein, weil das eine Wasserwerk hat ja sein Pumpwerk 1920 gekauft und betreiben das bis heute. Ich übertreibe nicht, das sind erwartbare Lebensdauer und das andere Wasserwerk, er hat irgendwie sein Pumpensystem 1970 neu gemacht, muss aber auch noch drei Hebewerke betreiben, um Abwasser aus einer Talsenke dahin zu befördern, wo das die Abwasserentsorgung ist. Er hat deswegen grundsätzlich andere Voraussetzungen. An einem Wasserwerk kriegt das hin, dass dazwischen eine Faser liegt, von mir aus in diesem hypothetischen Gedankenbeispiel, eine ganz spezielle Faser, die in einem Röhrchen verlegt ist, in dem ein Schutzgas läuft, wo du detektieren kannst, wenn der Druck abfällt, wenn das also irgendwie beschädigt sein könnte, dass du es vorher weißt, gibt es alles, kannst du kaufen für teuer Geld, machen wir an anderen Stellen auch so. Und das andere Wasserwerk sagt, hier ist ein Berg zwischen, das geht nicht, das Geld haben wir nicht, hier machen wir mal Richtfunksstrecke. Und dann kaufen die sich halt ihren Zeugs zusammen, dass die ihre Systeme anstattkriegen und steuern können. Und dann hast du ja nicht nur so dieses, oh wir kaufen jetzt Zentrales irgendwo ein, und dann hängst du in der Hotline, nee, da willst du ja eigentlich am liebsten den vokalen Ingenieur haben, der einen Dorf weiter wohnt, der im Krisenfall halt auch dann nachts um zwei geweckt werden kann und dann mal kurz rauskommt, der das alles gebaut hat, und der dir ganz genau sagen kann, in welchem Leitsordner das Passwort für die Richtfunksstrecke steht. Und den willst du halt als Stadtwerke haben.
Naja, aber, aber wisst ihr heute...
Dass du halt weißt, wie man fragen kann.
Also ja, wir reden jetzt aber in einer Stunde und ich dachte ja, heute wird es sozusagen was mit einer optimistischen Ausblick. Aber je länger wir reden, desto mehr komme ich an den Punkt, vielleicht ist doch das wieder ein Thema, über das ich eigentlich gar nicht so viel wissen wollte.
Darf ich, dann lege ich noch mal einen drauf.
Ja bitte.
Hast du schon mal was von Netzfrequenzstabilität gehört? War das schon mal ein Thema hier in der Sendung?
Bitte erkläre es nochmal.
Okay, also wir haben hier dieser 50 Hertz, das ist eine Betrabergesellschaft und auch ein wissenschaftlicher Wert der Frequenz.
Wir reden jetzt vom Stromnetz.
Wechselstrom, genau. Wechselstrom wechselt 50 mal in der Sekunde die Richtung und deswegen heißt der Wechselstrom und weil das 50 Mal passiert, sind es 50 Hertz.
Das kommt aus der Steckdose.
Genau, so und wenn das jetzt variiert, dann ist das schlecht. Also das kann ein bisschen variieren, so die erwartbare Größenordnung von 50 mHz. Also 50, 05 oder 49, 95. Das ist in Ordnung, wenn das in dem Bereich variiert. Damit können alle um und alle Geräte sind darauf vorbereitet. Diese 50 Hertz spiegeln sich direkt wieder in der Rotation der Kerne, der Turbinen und Generatoren in allen Kraftwerken. Die rotieren alle mit vereinfacht gesagt 50 Hertz. Wenn die Netzrequenz sinkt, rotieren die langsamer und andersherum. Wenn jetzt mehr Strom verbraucht wird als hergestellt wird, dann fängt die Netzrequenz an zu sinken und die Generatoren drehen sich langsamer. Andersherum genauso. Wenn das über den Grenzwert kommt von 200 millihertz, dann poppt die Sicherung. Wie viel Gigawatt muss ich spontan aus dem europäischen Verbundennetz ziehen, bevor die Netzrequenz auf 49, 8 sinkt? Die Antwort variiert je nachdem, wie man fragt, irgendwo zwischen 2 und 6 Gigawatt. Das klingt bestimmt von der Wetterlage ab, von der Tageszeit, von den Heißdampfreserven, vom Strommarkt. Es gibt schon ein paar Faktoren, aber so ist die Größenordnung. Wir sagen Hausnummer 3 Gigawatt. Jetzt haben wir in Deutschland ein halbes Gigawatt Lithium-Akkus am Start. 470, 480 Megawattstunden Kapazität.
Warte mal, rettest du jetzt gerade alle unsere Smartphone-Akkus zusammen genommen oder sind das Stromreserven-Akkus irgendwo rumsteht?
Nee, das Requenz-Ausgleichsanlagen. Das ist ein Schiffscontainer von der Lithium-Akkus, die auf der grünen Wiese stehen und die für, weiß ich nicht, 40 Centikilowattstunde sauteuer eine Ausgleichsleistung anbieten und die halt garantieren, dass sie binnen Sekunden, naja Megawatt da reinpumpen ins Netz, wenn das der Markt nachfragt. Und dafür, dass du diese Akkus ans Netz hängst, kriegst du halt Geld der Strombörse, weil das eine Ausgleichsleistung ist. So, und überlegen, 470, 480 Megawattstunden Kapazität haben wir, die kann man vielleicht in der Hälfte der Zeit, also mit 2C Kapazität, Modellbauer werden das noch kennen von Lithium-Akkus, ins Netz pumpen, so ungefähr die Größenordnung, also können wir ungefähr ein Gigawatt ausgleichen an Leistung. So, jetzt überlegen wir mal, nehmen wir mal so ein Router daher, hier vielleicht die W700V-Lücke, die 900.000 Geräte betroffen hat, da war jetzt nur so ein Home-Router mit 5 Watt Leistung, das ist jetzt kein größeres Problem, wenn der gebrochen ist, aber in zwei, drei Jahren kann man bestimmt sagen, dass, nehmen wir mal eine runde Zahl, 2, 4 Prozent der Haushalte, das ist genau eine Million, eine Million Haushalte, vielleicht so eine smarte Waschmaschine haben, oder so einen smarten Geschirrspieler, oder eine smarte Kaffeemaschine. Wenn du jetzt hier hingehst und mit NTP synchronisierst, also so ein Netzwerkzeitprotokoll über WLAN, geht das ganz gut, deine einzelnen Haushaltsverbraucher allesamt synchronisierst auf diese Netzfrequenz, ist das durchaus denkbar, dass sie alle gleichzeitig zum Peak der 50 Hertz Frequenz, wenn sie mal an der höchsten Stelle ist, die Heizspule für 10 Millisekunden einschalten, dann wird die nicht wirklich warm und der Besitzer merkt das nie wirklich, aber dann können wir damit schon reinrechnen, die 3 Gigawatt zusammenkriegen, die wir brauchen für Netzzusammenbruch. Nur über eine Million gehackte Waschmaschinen und das sind nur 2, 4 Prozent der Haushalte.
Da würde ich ja fast sagen, ich glaube, niemand würde das machen, sondern was man machen würde ist, man würde 1 Gigawatt nehmen und man ist dann nämlich der Betreiber dieser Lithium-Ionen-Ausgleichs-Akkus und dann hat man richtig cool Asche verdient.
Nee, nee, das hast du nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Du hast genauso viel wie vorher. Das ist ja diese Virtual-Netzbetreiber. Als Netzbetreiber musst du garantieren, dass du eine gewisse Menge Strom liefern kannst, dass du eine gewisse Ausgleichsleistung hast für Schwankungen. Wenn du aber als Kraftwerksbetreiber nur Windkraft oder nur Solar hast, kannst du an deiner vertraglichen Verpflichtung nicht mehr nachkommen, in dem Moment, wo eine Wolke vorzieht oder der Wind aufhört oder zu stark wird. Entsprechend schaltet man sich dann am Markt zusammen, teilt sich das Risiko auf oder jemand übernimmt das, indem er einen virtuellen Betreiber macht und der kauft dann den ungleichmäßigen Solarstrom, den ungleichmäßigen Windstrom, kauft noch ein bisschen Wasserkraft dabei, weil die ist eine konstante Größe, und ein bisschen Ausgleichsleistung. Und dann hat er die Garantie, dass er seine Versorgungsverpflichtungen am Markt auch erfüllen kann, zum Lieferzeitpunkt genau die Menge zu liefern, die der Markt dann gerade braucht.
Aber das heißt, diesen Hack, den du gerade beschrieben hast, den würde man nur aus der reinen Zerstörungsfreude machen, oder wenn man Geld erpressen will.
Na ja, du hast schon acht Wochen Schummausfall in ganz Europa, und ein Szenario, das wir nie geprobt haben, nämlich ein Anfahren von Schwarzstaat.
Wir wissen nicht, wie das geht.
In acht Wochen ist das konservativ gerechnet.
Ich muss mal mit der Kuh reden. Wer mir dieses Thema schon wieder eingebrockt hat, ich werde heute Nacht wieder nicht schlafen können. Vielen Dank!
Also das war jetzt das eine Beispiel, und das gibt es für alle kritischen Infrastrukturen in der Hochrechnung. Okay, ich kann für jeden Sektor so ein Ding finden, wo Menschen sterben.
Ich wähle Ernährung.
Wir gehen jetzt nicht alle durch. Komm, hör auf.
Nein, nein, ich möchte noch eins, und ich wähle Ernährung.
Gut, Ernährung, ja. Also du bist im Bereich Ernährung kritis, wenn du am Tag 600 Tonnen oder mehr Lebensmittel produzierst in deinem Lebensmittelwerk, dann bist du kritis. Wenn wir also jetzt so ein größeres Werk, da gibt es bestimmt auch welche geben hier, wir haben hier einen großen Fleischhabel in Betriebe, die machen, die waren ja auch gerade erst in Medien im Zusammenhang mit Corona, die produzieren wirklich, wirklich große Mengen Fleisch. In Gütersloh zum Beispiel. Naja, wenn die mal ausfallen, haben wir auch keinen Fleisch.
Moment, Moment, das Szenario jetzt gerade war so erschreckend, weil du sozusagen auch das Beispiel gebracht hast, wie das praktisch passieren kann. Wie geht denn so ein Fleischverarbeitungsbetrieb komplett vom Netz, vom Fleischnetz?
Naja, du musst dir überlegen, die kehlen da am Tag eine fünfstellige Anzahl Schweine, die kommt in eine vierstellige Anzahl LKWs. Und diese vierstellige Anzahl LKWs, die muss irgendwo, also ein LKW kann meiner Meinung nach so 50 bis 90 Schweine fassen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ich hab irgendwann mal bei einem Fleischverarbeitungsbetrieb gearbeitet als Jugendlicher. So, und das war so die Größenordnung, so ein Auflieger hatte 40 Schweinehälften oder so was. 40, 50 Schweinehälften, das war so die Größenordnung. Also irgendwie 50.000 Schweine am Tag irgendwie in deiner Facility Kills, dann hast du irgendwie auch eine vierstellige Menge LKWs, die dir auf den Hof fahren. Und wenn dein Logistiksystem nicht mehr weiß, welche LKW jetzt in welches Loading Bay muss, weil das kaputt ist, dann kannst du die LKW nicht mehr verarbeiten in dieser Menge und dieser Größenordnung.
Da muss man dann noch weniger kaputt machen, damit das schiefgeht. Hilfer! Ich hasse diese Welt.
Molkereibetriebe zählen damit auch dazu.
So, jetzt hat HonkHase die ganze Zeit immer schon Cyber, Cyber, Cyber gemacht. Ich habe für meinen Gefühl sich ein bisschen lustig mit diesem Begriff gemacht. Trotzdem, wenn man euch auf Twitter folgt, also generell zu sagen, wenn ihr einen überwegt habt, der Begriff Cyberware kommt da schon vor. Was ist das? Was soll das?
Also das ist die Lösung. Also wir haben ja jetzt die Angst gemacht. Das wollten wir ja auch.
Warte mal, ihr seid in Wirklichkeit so eine Art Zeugen Jehovas?
Das ist schon abgekrasst. Wir sind die Zeugen Cyber-Hovas. Oh, das ist geil. Wir sind Cyber-Hovas.
Okay, I'm listening.
Also wir haben uns gedacht, du hast ja auch stets die Zentralisierung vorgeschlagen als mögliche Lösung. Und an vielen Stellen ist das aber schon so. 90, 95, 98 Prozent der IT, die die Menschen so anfassen, da draußen ist halt irgendwie Windows. Und wir haben eine Infrastruktur gebaut, die Leuten Windows beibringt. Also Arbeitsagentur zum Beispiel bringt Menschen Windows bei, nicht Linux. Finde ich auch seltsam, aber es ist so. Und in dem Moment, wo also eine massive Risikerslücke in dem Windows-System auftaucht und ein Hacker dahinter ein bisschen malicious ist oder sagen wir mal hochkriminell, dann ist er kein Hacker mehr, ne? Dann ist er kein Hacker mehr, aber dann wird es halt gefährlich. Und in diesen Monokulturen haben wir uns gedacht, braucht es eine Instant-Response und zwar eine Instant-Response, die erst dann ausrückt, wenn nicht das einzelne Haus brennt, sondern der Straßenzug und dann so fungiert, ähnlich wie ein THW da draußen, aber halt virtuell. Ein CHW, ein Cyber-Hills-Werk. Also nicht für der Bach, bei uns im Dorf ist irgendwie ein bisschen Hochwasser, kommt die Feuerwehr, pumpt den Keller wieder leer. Kann noch mal zwei Tage dauern, wenn die busy ist, aber irgendwann wird sie kommen und pumpt den Keller wieder leer. Aber wenn von Dresden bis Hamburg so Hochwasser ist, dann kommt die lokale Feuerwehr nicht mehr, dann kommt das THW und die Bundeswehr.
Aber was macht dann so ein CHW? Weil in den Szenarien, die ihr jetzt beschrieben habt, ist es ja eigentlich zu spät, wenn man irgendjemand anruft.
Naja, das THW kommt auch erst, wenn es zu spät ab. Also die kommen ja nicht präventiv, die kommen ja reaktiv, ne?
Naja, gut, aber das THW kommt und tut dann noch Säcke auf den Deich. Vielleicht verhindert man das Schlimmste. Bei den Szenarien, die ihr jetzt beschrieben habt, ist es ja so, das macht Peng und dann ist alles weg.
Genau. Und dann musst du halt im Zweifel zum Beispiel diese Millionen-Waschmaschine tatsächlich patchen. Indem du halt hingehst, klingelst, sagst, ich bin von der Waschmaschine, ich bin vom CHW. So, da ein Stecker ransteckst, auf den Knopf drückst, den Chip patcht und den Stecker wieder abziehst, wenn du wieder rausgehst. Geiler Engel-Trick. Und das machst du dann, du repeatst eine Million, und das dann aber, alleine geht das nicht. Wenn das Bedingung ist, bis das Stromnetz wieder angefahren werden kann, dann musst du das parallelisieren, dann brauchst du dafür ein paar hundert, vielleicht sogar ein paar tausend Menschen, die das tun können. Bei anderen Geschichten ist das vielleicht ähnlich. Bei sehr zentralen Infrastruktur kann das reichen, wenn da nur so eine kleine Größenordnung von Leuten ist, 10, 12, 15 oder sowas, weiß ich nicht. Zwei, drei, vier ziehen Panik-Backups, fünf, sechs, sieben machen Forensik auf den Log-Files. Ein, zwei Leute halten die Geschäftsführung und den Vorstand in Schach und kommunizieren mit denen. Und irgendwer koordiniert den Rest der Instant-Response, bis man einen Patch hat.
Aber ich finde das total nachvollziehbar. Das ist noch mal ein ganz spannendes Ding, dass wir ja über dieses Smart-Home-Ding, bei uns zu Hause stehen irgendwie 40.000 IP-fähige Geräte. Und vielleicht kommt natürlich mal der Punkt, wo man sicherstellen muss, dass die alle gepatcht werden. Das Ehrenamtliche, was das THW auch hat, ist auch Teil dieser Überlegungen?
Es ist auf jeden Fall. Es ist gedanklich und konzeptionell sehr nah am THW dran, was wir da vorhaben.
Das finde ich total nachvollziehbar. Und ich finde das auch nachvollziehbar, dass man sagt, man hat sozusagen so eine Elite-Einsatztruppe für diese zentralen Dinge. Aber an der Stelle frage ich mich, warum gibt es das nicht? Und warum gibt es das nicht als offiziell, als Behörde, als staatliche Behörde?
Ja, gibt es als staatliche Behörde, finden wir auch gut, begrüßen wir. Wir sind auch im Gespräch mit den Leuten da. Das ist das Mobile Incident Response Team. Und die sind angeordnet im BSI, im Bundesamt für Sicherheit, in der Informationstechnik, also einer der Unterbehörden des BMI.
Warte mal, ist das BSI? Sind das nicht die, die auch dafür zuständig sind, im Exploit-Markt Sachen zu kaufen? Aber die sind doch auch beim BMI, oder? Um es so rum zu erklären, das BSG ist nicht unabhängig vom BMI. Ich muss es kurz sagen, ich hab mir jetzt selber zu weit rausgeritten. Also liebe Hörerinnen, es ist ja so. Vielleicht habt ihr die Diskussion um die aktuelle Wiederauflebung der Idee des Staatsruhianners mitbekommen. Es gibt immer mal wieder in der Politik die Idee, dass es okay ist, auf den Laptop von irgendjemanden, der verdächtig ist, was auch immer, Schadsoftware aufzuspielen, um den zu belauschen. Um das zu machen, muss man Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen. Diese Sicherheitslücken kann man entweder selber rausfinden oder man kann sie kaufen. Und es gibt immer wieder eine spannende Diskussion, ob staatliche Stellen, die für die IT-Sicherheit zuständig sind, vielleicht auch dazu beitragen, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Sicherheitslücken den Geheimdiensten zur Verfügung stehen. Und das ist, also hier entscheidet es gerade nicht der Fall. Und dann ist immer noch die Frage, wie nahe sind diese Einheiten?
Also das Problem, was du ansprichst, ist ja die fehlende Unabhängigkeit des BSI vom BMI, vom Bundesinnenministerium. Und die zuständigen Mitarbeiter oder Fachbereiche sind ja zuständig für Sicherheitsbehörden und BSI. Das heißt, in deren Brust schlagen zwei Herzen, will schützen vor Terrorphasen nicht gesehen und will aber auch die Bevölkerung schützen. Und genau diese nicht vorhandene Unabhängigkeit ist ein Problem, und zwar wirklich. Deswegen hat auch die Ag Kritis als eine der Forderungen, dass wir eine deutlich höhere Unabhängigkeit eines BSI brauchen von sowas, damit sie eben nicht zum Handlanger oder Anreicherung von solchen Dingen, die du da gerade angesprochen hast, zur Verfügung stehen. Sie sollen ausschließlich den Cyber-Schutz-Gewährleistung-Punkt. Also jetzt, in diesem Zeitpunkt, macht das BSI sowas nicht. Das BSI hat einen üblen Track-Record von einem bekannten Case, wo sie quasi den Backchannel von einer früheren Start-Zu-Einer-Version für das BKA auditiert haben und gesagt haben, ja, so ist das sicher und verschlüsselt. Das haben sie gemacht. Es ist nicht ihre Aufgabe, sowas zu machen, aber das BMI und nur das BMI kann das BSI anweisen, sowas zu tun. Das BMI hat die Fach- und Rechtsaufsicht über das BSI. Und im Rahmen dieser Fachaufsicht kann das BMI das anweisen. Die Rechtsaufsicht wird wahrscheinlich Birken am Bundesministerium bleiben müssen. Die Fachaufsicht könnte man aber einer Unterbehörde auch selbst geben. Zum Beispiel das Bundesamt für Statistik ist genauso aufgesetzt. Da ist die Rechtsaufsicht irgendein Ministerium. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, welches. Und die Fachaufsicht hat nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien durch den Präsidenten der Behörde zu erfolgen. So ginge das beim BSI auch. Da gibt es noch vier, fünf andere Varianten. Die haben wir als Ag Kritis auch mal diskutiert. Ich glaube, wir haben noch einen Blogpost dazu geschrieben. Zumindest mal Svenns Forderungen dazu verlinkt. Also da gibt es eine Debatte dazu, wie man das genau juristisch machen könnte, das BSI-Unabhängige zu machen. Und wir sind dafür, das zu tun.
Wo waren wir vorher? Wir sind genau an der Stelle, wo wir richtig gut sind. Und zwar kommen wir zu dem Punkt Ag Kritis. Das ist ja etwas sozusagen...
Ah, nirrt. Genau, wir waren beim Mobile-Incent-Response-Team. Eigentlich.
Im BSI.
Ja, das hat sie ja schon erklärt.
Genau. Gut, kommen wir jetzt zu Ag Kritis. Ein Name, der immer wieder gefallen ist, wo ihr sozusagen Mitglieder seid. Und wo sich jetzt die Frage stellt, will die Ag Kritis dieses CHW sein? Oder ist das eine Lobby-Organisation dafür, diese Strukturen, die ihr jetzt skizziert habt, zu schaffen?
Das Weitere. Letzteres, ganz klar. Die Ag Kritis ist ein Zusammenschluss aus 42 Experten. Ich habe gerade im Streamer-Channel nachgeguckt, wir sind 42. 42 Mitglieder haben wir. Alle 42 sind Experten im Bereich IT-Sicherheit, im Bereich Kritis. Und Expertinnen. Expertinnen haben wir inzwischen glücklicherweise auch. Sehr erfreulich. Und diese, sagen wir es sich, Mitglieder, sind beruflich beschäftigt mit dem Zeugs durch Auditierung, durch Entwicklung, durch Fixen, durch Internet-Response, durch Software-Entwicklung, durch Abministration und durch Beratung oder Beratungsunternehmen. Und wir haben natürlich auch eine Handvoll Kritis-Auditoren in unseren Reihen. Und wir als zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation haben uns zur Aufgabe gemacht, die sogenannten Bewältigungskapazitäten zur Bewältigung von Cyber-Sicherheitsvorfällen, also Großschadenslagen, die durch Cyber-Sicherheitsvorfälle hervorgerufen wurden, dass wir da die Bewältigungskapazitäten ausbauen wollen. Das ist originär eine staatliche Aufgabe, das können wir nicht selbst tun, aber wir können eine Blaupause machen, ein Konzept machen, dass bei der Zielgruppe, nämlich Hacker, Nerds, ehrenamtliche, IT-affine, Computerliebhaber und Leute, die gerne Spielzeug haben, attraktiv ist. Das hat der Staat nicht verstanden, das kann der Staat auch nicht verstehen. Aber wenn der Innenminister 2015 zum Vorstand der CCC sagt, ich hätte da gerne mal eine Hotline von ihnen für eine solche Großschadenslage und der CCC sagen muss, nachvollziehbarerweise sagen muss, gibt's nicht, haben wir nicht, dann erkennt man daran aber schon den großen Bedarf in der Politik für eine ehrenamtliche, zivilgesellschaftliche Notfallorganisation, ähnlich wie das Rote Kreuz, 600.000 Freiwillige oder das THW mit irgendwie auch so sechsstelliger Menge an Freiwilligen, die in der Krise oder nur in der Krise unseren Arsch retten könnten, vielleicht. Oder zumindest die Krise abmildern können. Und der Staat wird das nie vorbeigestellen können und alles, was der Staat oder das BSI oder das BMI dazu bauen kann, wird von den Nerds, den Hackern, den Leuten, die man da braucht als Ehrenamtliche, als Freiwillige, ausgelacht werden und das wahrscheinlich zu Recht. Deswegen haben wir, Ag Kritis, uns gedacht, wir müssen denen mal eine Blaupause schreiben. Ein Konzept, worauf sie achten müssen, wie das gehen könnte, dass man so eine Hilfsorganisation hat. Die haben es auch schon mal versucht, eine Cyberware zu bauen, indem sie qua Gesetz oder Verordnung oder Vertrag oder Abkommen dafür sorgen wollten, dass Mitarbeiter aus IT-Sicherheitsabteilungen in Unternehmen zu so etwas zusammengezogen werden können. Der Versuch wurde geschadet, der Versuch ist gescheitert aufgrund komplexer juristischer Sachverhalte, also Mittelwerbsrecht, Kartellrecht und aus anderen Rechtsgebieten. Nehmen wir Überlassungen und so weiter. Genau, da gab es ganz komische Dinge. Es ist gescheitert, deswegen gibt es aktuell staatlich keine Bemühungen, was in die Art nochmal zu versuchen, weil daran haben sich auch Beamte und Behördenmitarbeiter verbrannt. Die haben darauf gepokert, dass es was wird, haben das Projekt vorangetrieben und jetzt ist das Projekt gescheitert anhand von juristischen Gründen, deswegen haben sie sich verbrannt. Deswegen werden die relevanten Abteilungen im BSI jetzt auf absehbare Zeit sowas erstmal nicht versuchen. Aber wenn wir Nerds selbst ankommen, uns ein halbwegs seriöses Aussehen geben, gucken wir unser Logo an, so langweilig geht es ja gar nicht, das ist perfekt seriös. Kannst du nichts gegen sagen und sich mal aufschreiben, wie das funktionieren müsste. Dann haben wir Hoffnung, dass der Staat das nimmt, copypastet, als eigenes verkauft und sagt, guck mal, wir haben ein Cyber-Hillswerk gebaut. Und das Schöne als kleine Ergänzung, das BSI wie auch das BBK, die haben sich wirklich mit uns zusammengesetzt in Workshops und haben gesagt, so, reden wir mal über ein Cyber-Hillswerk, wie könnte das aussehen und worauf müsst ihr noch achten. Das Ultrageile ist, ein Jurist aus dem BSI wurde mitgesponsert, der ist gekommen und hat gesagt, so Leute, ich erkläre euch mal juristisch, was bei uns kacke gelaufen ist und die Fehler macht ihr nicht auch in diesem Konzept. Das hier ist der Plan, das hier sind die Fails und da sind die Lösungen, darauf müsst ihr achten. Das war zum Beispiel sehr cool, denn dieses Cyber-Hilfskonstrukt, was sie damals als Cyberware nutzen wollten und da mit der Fehlerkultur offen zu uns zu kommen und zu sagen, auf diese Punkte müsst ihr achten, damit es gut wird, das fand ich mega cool.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Fragen. Das eine ist, mir kreuzen sich jedes Mal, wenn ich das Wort Cyber höre, die Fußnägel hoch, weil das jahrelang ein sicherer Anscheinensbeweis dafür ist, dass jemand keine Ahnung hat, wenn er Cyber sagt. Warum habt ihr euch dafür entschieden, das so offensiv zu benutzen? Ist das ein Marketing-Gag, also Marketing im Sinne von, das viral in den Köpfen der Leute festzuhalten, die das geil finden oder?
Es geht halt um mehr als nur IP oder Virtualisierung oder Digitalisierung, weil du sozusagen diesen gesamten, also Cyberraum beschreibt es schon so schön schwammig. Es kann alles Mögliche dazu kommen wie Industrial IoT, was vor Jahren kein Thema war, kann aber auch eine große Schadenslage bewirken. Es deckt Dinge ab wie Prozesse und Menschen, denn es ist nicht nur ein Maschinenproblem.
Ich verstehe die Motivation, einen Begriff zu finden, der ein bisschen weiter was sagt als nur IP oder IT oder sowas. Aber der Begriff Cyber im politischen Kontext ist ja nun nicht so geil besetzt.
Wir versuchen ihn geil zu besetzen. Aus Community-Sicht können wir immer behaupten, das wäre ironisch gemeint. Aus straflicher Sicht ist das ein hoch seriöser, mehr der Wiener klar definierter Begriff, den jeder andere auch benutzt. Worunter die Menschen sich was vorstellen können. Dass das negativ konnotiert ist, ist vermutlich in deiner Filterblase so. Da draußen eher nicht so. Das ist nur ein relativ wertneutrales Wort, das noch breiter ist als IT. Nämlich auch alle anderen Kategorien, also OT und Netze und Menschen und Prozesse. Und was HonkHase gerade sagte, alles mit abdeckt und relativ vage bleibt.
Ich versuche, mich daran zu gründen. Das andere ist, jetzt ist ja der Incident Response. Also die Tatsache, dass man auf Dinge, die kaputt sind, in IT-Systemen reagiert. Da hatten wir auch mal eine eigene Folge, das war die 236, wo das ein bisschen als Beruf beschrieben wurde. Und das ist genau der Punkt. Jetzt kann man da ja sehr gut Geld verdienen. Also Incident Response-Firmen sind nicht die Ärmsten auf der Welt, glaube ich. Und jetzt ist ja, wenn so eine Ag-Kritis daherkommt, sagt, hier, mach doch mal so und so, könnte man, also jetzt mal die Perspektive einnehmen, zwei Sachen, die eine ist, Moment mal, ihr macht uns hier das schöne Geschäft kaputt, dass wir Millionen damit aus der Notlage von Menschen schaffen können und das andere ist ja, Moment mal, wenn ihr das vorschlagt, landet ihr zufälligerweise auch auf den Chessesseln, wie auch immer die Struktur aussieht?
Nein, also die Idee dahinter ist ja folgende, du gehst ja auch nicht deine eigene Bude anzünden, um zu sagen, jetzt kommt die Freiwillige Feuerwehr, weil die Berufsfeuerwehr reicht nicht aus und ich will Chef der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr werden. Das CRW soll auch nicht ausrücken, wenn du einen Sicherheitsvorfall oder einen Incident Response benötigst, sondern die rückt aus, wenn du eine Großschadenslage hast. Also das CRW kommt ja auch nicht, weil jemand sich einen Zähnagel gebrochen hat und die kommen auch nicht, wenn jemand sagt, wir haben hier so einen Fluss, der ist über Wasser, sondern wenn der scheiß Fluss durch ganz Deutschland läuft und über Wasser ist, dann kommen die und zwar mit vielen 1000 Mann im Worst Case an ganz vielen Stellen. Und das CAW rückt dann auch in dieser Logik nur aus, wenn wir eine Großschadenslage haben und nicht, wenn jemand sich ein paar Euro 50 für eine Incident Response sparen will. Denn da das ja dann im Idealfall, so wie unser Konzept das vorsieht, durch eine, wie nennt sich das, Ijon, das kannst du jetzt glaube ich besser erklären, eine offizielle Anfrage, übernimm du einfach mal. Wann kommt es, wenn welche formalen Dinge ins Leben gerufen werden? Also die Alarmierung kann erst dann erfolgen, wenn das zuständige Ministerium, also Bundesministerium, die Großschadenslage ausruft und definiert. So dann kann das THW kommen nicht vorher. Ja, es gibt Ausnahmen, das THW kannste dazu benutzen, dass sich ein Waltersbaum aufstellt, irgendwie einmal im Jahr, dann ist das eine Übung für die Mitglieder. Das geht schon und die können eventuell auch eine Glusche runter aufstellen, fürs Feuerwehrfest. So, aber einsatzmäßig muss das schon von ganz ganz oben kommen, also vom Innenminister. In der Realität ist es ein bisschen komplexer. Da gibt es noch Staatssekretäre dazwischen, die das auch tun könnten, aber vereinfacht erklärt ist es, der Innenminister muss sagen, Großschadenslage, shit hits the fan, Kotstücke fliegen überall, das ist jetzt schlecht. Wir machen mal die Großschadenslage, die bundesweite Krise und alarmieren das THW dazu. Beim THW wäre es nicht anders. Also erst, wenn die Großschadenslage so groß ist, dass alle staatlichen und alle privatwirtschaftlichen Kräfte und Personen und Unternehmen augenscheinlich nicht den Hauch einer Chance haben, die Lage in den Griff zu kriegen, erst dann müsste man so ein THW alarmieren. Und auf gar keinen Fall vorher, weil vorher haben wir ja die Unternehmen und die Wirtschaft und ein paar Ehrenamtler und ein paar Nachtschichten und Überstunden und obendrein auch noch das Mobile Instant Response Team mit etwa 30 Personen vom BSI, das bei größeren Sachen auch schon mal helfen kann. Aber wenn du diese 30 Personen halt in 600 Krankenhäuser schicken musst, um in 600 Krankenhäuser gleichzeitig ein kritisches Stück Systemkomponente zu reparieren, dann geht das halt nicht. Und dann kannst du halt überlegen, nimmst du einen THW, wobei selbst dann hast du vielleicht noch Chancen auf den Markt Instant Responder ranzukriegen. Aber irgendwann musst du als Start halt auch sagen, ich ziehe Notbremse und ich hole jetzt Leute hier ran, auch gegen den Willen deren Arbeitgeber. Das ist am THW nämlich auch so. Wenn THW Einsatz ist, dann können sie dir als Mitglied einfach sagen, jetzt ist der Einsatz befohlen, bitte, jetzt in den Einsatz. Und dein Arbeitgeber kriegt dann dein Bruttogehalt entschädigt. Aber der kann nicht sagen, nee, geht nicht.
Also ich bin freiwillig Teil des THWs, oder dann ausgedacht THWs. Also das entscheide ich freiwillig, dass ich dabei bin. Aber wenn ich dabei bin, dann kann ich sozusagen freigestellt werden. Das wäre der Idealfall.
Dann sagt der Innenminister Monoxid, du musst jetzt mal bitte hier ins Einsatz. Und dein Arbeitgeber wird dann entschädigt und hat da kein Mitspracherecht mehr. Also das ist, was unser Konzept vorsieht. Das heißt nicht, dass es so zwingend kommen muss. Aber wir haben gesagt, dass es einen blöden Sinn macht.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage, die möglicherweise damit zu tun hat, dass ich zu lange hier auf diesem Platz gesessen habe und Leute darüber gefragt haben, wie sie Dinge kaputt machen. Und zwar, wenn das THW kommt, dann hilft es sozusagen, dass Sachen nicht noch kaputter gehen, als sie gerade schon sind. Oder Fluss über die Ufer, Dinge brennen, Sachen sind zusammengestürzt, was auch immer. Oder helfen vielleicht sogar beim Wiederaufbau. Jetzt sind ja technische Systeme, also gerade dieses, entschuldigt mein böses Denken, aber ein Krankenhaus muss also Patch einspielen. Und das müssen gerade 600 Krankenhäuser. Und das ist doch total cool, dann der Typ zu sein, der da reingeht, den USB-Stick an alle Computer steckt und diesen Patch aufspielt und diese kleine Zusatzsoftware. Hintergrund der Frage ist also, wie stellt ihr euch vor, welche Leute da mitmachen? Weil ich mir das wirklich vorstellen kann, und das also wirklich schwieriger vorstelle als bei einem THW, dass du sagst, die müssen genug Ahnung haben, um das überhaupt machen zu können. Und die müssen aber auch in einem ganz besonderen Maße vertrauenswürdig sein.
Der erste Schritt ist ja, dass sie nicht alleine agieren bei einem Vorfall, sondern natürlich immer gemeinsam mit dem Kritis-Betreiber agieren. Die gehen ja nicht in den Luft deren Raum und sagen, geht mal aus dem Weg, ich bin THW und ich mach jetzt hier Dinge an eurem System. Du brauchst immer, du brauchst immer, immer, immer den Kritis-Betreiber und die Know-how-Träger der Infrastruktur, mit denen du gemeinsam das Ganze abstimmst. Alles andere wäre ein Inferno. Das heißt, der Betreiber guckt da schon auf die Finger. Bekloppt sind die ja nicht. Und das ist schon mal die erste selbstkorrektive Variante. Die zweite ist, dass es in allen einsatzfahrenden Organisationen, Polizei, Feuerwehr, Krankenwagen, THW, scheißegal, da siehst du eigentlich nie die Leute alleine. Die haben eh mal einen Kollegen dabei, die sind zu zweit im Auto, die fahren auch zu zweit irgendwo hin. Das macht schon Sinn, weil da kann der eine Hilfe holen, wenn der andere ein Problem hat. Das ist schon clever, das könnte man auch einfach übernehmen. Umdrehen ist das ja auch jetzt keine Geschichte, wo du ohne jegliche menschlichen Kontakt sofort in Einsatz kommst, sondern da wird eine wahrscheinlich umfassende Ausbildung in verschiedenen Themenbereichen vorher erfolgen. Im Rahmen davon, man die Menschen und Kandidaten auch kennenlernen kann und faule Eier aussortieren oder bitten zu gehen. Das ist beim THW ja nicht anders. Die haben ja auch durchaus ein Kippe, mit dem man einen feinen Fug machen kann, nachdem man sie einsetzt. Ich denke, das kriegt man in den Griff. Und am Ende gibt es immer noch die Strafbarkeit. Wer sowas macht, der kommt halt in den Knast. Das wird nicht allzu häufig passieren, weil es ist ja am Ende auch relativ klar, wer das dann war. Was wir unter anderem auch im Konzept vorgesehen haben, ist zum Beispiel eine grundsatzethische Ausbildung. Nämlich wirklich zu sagen, du gehörst zu den Guten und verstehst, was das heißt an Verantwortung und so weiter. Und das wollen wir natürlich auch in eine Richtung treiben, zu sagen, wir wollen ja bewusst die Hacker-Community dazu aktivieren, im CAW freiwillig zu agieren. Weil das sind ja Know-how-Träger, die Dinge kaputt spielen können oder wieder ganz machen. Und auch mal unkonventionell denken, um in einer Problemsituation eine flexible Lösung zu erarbeiten. Und die kriegst du halt nicht, wenn du sagst, ja, das CAW kann natürlich auch militärische Einsätze fahren, würde auch mal als Ersatzdienstleistung bei einer dunkeldeutschen Sicherheitsbehörde komische Dinge aus Gründen tun oder so. Also wir haben auch klar zu verstehen gegeben in dem Konzept, entweder ist das Ganze ethisch korrekt aufgezogen oder eine Totgeburt. Und das hat zum Beispiel dann auch ein offizieller Vertreter des CCC durchaus in den Workshops auch zu verstehen gegeben und hat gesagt, dieses Spiel kann nur funktionieren, wenn ein Innenministerium oder wie auch immer eine Behörde, Institution, whatever ins Leben ruft und das ethisch korrekt ausrichtet. Wenn da irgendein Hasenfurz nach komisch riecht, ist vorbei. Dann werden wir einmal ganz laut sagen, so geht es nicht. Und dann ist das Ding kaputt bei Design. Das muss sowohl den ins Leben rufenden Behörden als auch den Teilnehmern klar sein, dass das ganz schnell Ärger gibt. Das ist ja auch das Schöne am THW, dass das THW schon besetzlich und durch Verträge internationaler Arten einer Staaten rein defensiv aufgebaut ist. Das THW genießt den gleichen Schutz wie ein Fahrzeug mit dem roten Kreuz drauf in einem Kriegsgebiet. Das darfst du nicht aktiv beschießen oder angreifen. Oder musst du annehmen, dass das friedlich ist und dir nichts tun wird, auch wenn es dem Gegner gehört. Das ist schon so ein Feldlazarett, darfst du nicht angreifen. Im gleichen Sinne und den gleichen Schutz genießt das THW. Daraus folgt aber auch, dass THW-Mitglieder selbst in gefährlichen Einsatzgebieten keine Waffen tragen dürfen. Und auch keinen Waffeneinsatz durchführen dürfen. Die Bundesregierung kann das THW nicht dazu bringen, dass sie Bunkeranlagen in Afghanistan springen. Obwohl sie das wohl sehr gerne gehabt hätten, dass man das tut, weil die Bundeswehr damit überfordert war, das durchzuführen. Man hat dann freundlich gefragt, bekam ein sehr deutliches Nein und dann war es erledigt. Und in der gleichen Weise müsste ein THW geschützt sein, damit ein Trojanereinsatz oder eine Überwachungsmaßnahme oder Vergleichbares halt nicht von einem Dienstleister THW übernommen werden kann, sondern da muss eine klare Limitierung auf defensive Handlungen, auf ethisch korrekte Sachen, alles, was kriegerisch oder straferfolgerisch ist. Dafür gibt es andere Behörden, das muss klar und sauber getrennt sein. Und dazu ist vielleicht auch kein Zufall, dass eine große Überlagerung zwischen Ag Kritis und Veranstaltungsausrichter und vollverantwortliche Veranstalter der DefensiveCon sind, was aber trotzdem eigentlich zwei Paar Schuhe sind.
Du musst aber kurz erklären, was ein DefensiveCon ist.
Genau, das will ich erklären. Drei der fünf DefensiveCon-Veranstalter sind auch Ag-Kritis-Mitglieder. Die DefensiveCon wurde im Februar dieses Jahr zum zweiten Mal ausgerichtet. Das Hauptthema war defensiv statt offensiv und Ethik in der korrekten Ausrichtung. Da wurde unser Cyber-Hilfswerk-Konzept in der ersten und initialen Version 1.0 zum ersten Mal in der Öffentlichkeit vorgestellt. Auf der DefensiveCon wurden aber auch z.B. hat der BSI Myrd Leiter mal erzählt, wie Einsatzvorfälle bei kritischen Infrastrukturen sind. Da haben auch Leute Völkerrecht z.B. erklärt und interpretiert. All diese ethischen Defensivmaßnahmen und was der Gegenteil von dem offensiven Geraffel ist, sind ausführlich dargestellt. Es sind insgesamt 15 oder 16 Vorträge, die findet man auf media.ccc.de, frei verfügbar. Auch die Foliensätze sind alle online. Wir haben das schon bewusst in eine so nahe Lage dahin gebracht, damit es ganz klar ist, woher diese Signalrichtung kommt. Nämlich aus der Defensive, aus der Katastrophenhilfe, aus dem Helfen, nachdem es Peng gemacht hat, und zwar richtig groß pengen und nicht. Oder ist was passiert, schickt die mal dahin.
Ich habe noch zwei, drei Fragen, bevor wir zum Schluss kommen. Die eine ist, von dem, was ihr erzählt habt, entnehme ich, dass es auf der Fachebene ein Interesse gibt, dass man aber gerade so ein bisschen vorsichtig ist, weil man sich noch die Finger dran verbrannt hat. Gibt es sozusagen schon eine parteipolitische Ausrichtung, wo man sagen kann, das finden eigentlich alle cool, oder große Koalitionen finden es doof, Oppositionen finden es gut. Gibt es schon einen parteipolitischen Standpunkt dazu, oder ist das dazu noch zu sehr am Anfang?
Selbst wenn es den gäbe, wäre das hier nicht der Rahmen, um ihnen breit zu treten. Selbstverständlich wollen wir dieses Konzept umsetzen, und wir wollen, dass der Staat das umsetzt. Das heißt, eigentlich müssen wir mit all den Parteien reden, bei denen es eine hinreichende Chance gibt, dass sie bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl eine Regierungskoalition bilden könnten.
Das ist klar und leuchtet ein, aber es gibt noch keinen Stadt.
Diese Gespräche führt man hinter verschlossenen Türen. Wenn die aus ideologischen Gründen mit unabhängigem Naturschutz reinschreiben, wenn sie es als Ministerium aufbauen, schreibe ich gerne auch Schutz der Natur mit rein, als Schadenslage, die es zu berücksichtigen könnte, wenn die Partei, von der ich rede, an die Macht kommen könnte. Wenn die CDU ganz andere Forderungen hat, dann können wir auch darüber reden und gucken, wo man sich annähern kann. Aber genau dieser Abstimmungsprozess ist etwas, wo ein Geschaltungsspielraum da ist. Und am Ende muss jeder MDB, jeder Politiker, auch in der Lage sein zu sagen, ich hatte eine großartige Idee, guck mal. Das Paper stand aber von wem anders. Und die Kollegen und Mitarbeiter, die da in den Büros arbeiten, haben genauso wenig Zeit wie ich. Und deswegen, wenn man denen den Paper zuschieben kann und sagen, ich werde zu diesem Paper nicht sagen, dass ich der Autor war, auf gar keinen Fall, kannst du gerne dran schreiben deinen Namen und deinen Copyright, ist mir egal. Aber hier hast du einen Text, kannst du vielleicht als Formulierungshilfe verwenden. So, dann passiert da auch mal was.
Ich komme mir gerade vor wie in der Serie Parlament. Wenn ihr die gelegen habt, die zu gucken, schaut die mal.
Und genau auf diese Weise können wir da jetzt auch weiter voran schreiben. Für die Grünen schreibt man so eine Formulierungshilfe. Anders als für die Union, ist klar.
Das ist nicht nur eine Lektion hier, die wir heute gelernt haben in kritischer Infrastruktur und IT, sondern auch noch an Lobbyismus für Politik. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen diese Ecke. Die andere Ecke ist ja, wenn es so ein CHW gäbe, bräuchte das ja eben Freiwillige. Und jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, wenn ihr also dieses Ding habt, da sind 42 Leute drin, habt ihr diesen DefensiveCon gemacht, dass wenn man sich ein paar Leute mehr gesehen haben, es wird also mindestens so eine Bubble geben. Aber habt ihr eine grobe Vorstellung, wie so die generelle Stimmung in eurer Zielgruppe, der HackerInnen eben, ist, da mitzumachen? Oder spielt ihr auch die Gefahr, dass man so... Ja, also alle finden es eine geile Idee, aber dann will halt niemand mehr mitmachen, weil das ist ja schon Aufwand.
Na ja, an ein paar Stellen gab es schon vehemente Gegensprech. Es ist, glaube ich, auch kein Geheimnis, weil wer sich die DefensiveCon-Videos anguckt, wird auch sehen, dass Fefe da sehr dagegen war und gesagt hat, warte, dann sparen die sich nämlich alle genau die Kosten. Das ist ja irgendwie total schlecht. Also das Szenario, was du angebracht hattest, wir haben halt gesagt, nee, nee, das kommt ja nur bei Großschadenslagen und nicht bei jedem, der da Bock hat, Geld zu sparen. Insofern natürlich diese Vorbehalte gibt es und die sind auch insofern gut, weil wir uns dann mit diesen Fragestellungen auseinandersetzen und sagen, decken wir das ab in unserem Szenario? In dem Fall ja. Aber es gab auch nach der Vorstellung auf der DefensiveCon Initial und auch danach, ist ja auf unserer Webseite verlinkt, gab es sehr oft Anfragen an uns direkt oder an die Ag Kritis, wirklich echt Dutzende von Anfragen, wo kann ich beitreten, wo kann ich mitmachen, guck mal, ich hab folgende Experience, ich bin Experte im Krankenhaus für diese und jene Komponenten, ich mach schon seit Jahren Skada, Weilwegen, wo kann ich da mitmachen? Die waren alle total heiß und geil drauf, zu sagen, jetzt ich hier Einsatz. Und viele haben es sogar so vermengt, dass sie dann gesagt haben, hier, wo kann ich der Ag Kritis beitreten, ich will CRW machen, ich will helfen, ich hab dieses Helfersyndrom, ich hab die Ahnung, lasst mich das machen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, das ist nicht ag kritisch, wir entwickeln das Konzept und versuchen, Bevölkerungsschutz für Cybergroßschadenslagen und andere Dinge zu tun. Aber wenn ein CRW irgendwann vom Staat gegründet wird, dann werden wir einen Pointer geben und sagen, hier, da könnt ihr euch melden und da könnt ihr mitmachen. Also, war wirklich viel Zuspruch.
Aber kann man sich da jetzt, also wenn man jetzt das da, ha, geil denkt, kann man sich jetzt schon irgendwo einschreiben, eine Mailingliste, was auch immer, wo genau das passiert?
Haben wir diskutiert und haben wir uns dagegen entschieden, weil wir uns wirklich nicht den Anschein geben wollen, als hätten, als wären wir das CHW. Wir können halt nur aus der Community heraus ein Konzept schaffen, das von der Community akzeptiert wird.
Ja, verstehe ich, verstehe ich. Aber die Vorhaut des Menschen ist in Betracht gezogen. Ich erkenne an, ihr seid die Lobby-Organisation, die das macht. Und falls das Erfolg hat, möchte ich davon erfahren, und dann mache ich auch gerne mit, zwischendurch möchte ich nichts damit zu tun haben. Was abonniere ich, damit das passiert?
Du guckst regelmäßig ins Blog der Ag Kritis, hörst Podcasts wie Chaosradio oder... Zum Beispiel, genau.
Das heißt, wir machen also auf jeden Fall noch ein Chaosradio, falls das geklappt hat.
Sehr gerne.
Verhaftet. Okay. Genau, und die andere Frage wäre aber trotzdem, also wir haben gelernt, also CHW, das ist etwas, das dann kommen soll, dann braucht man da viele Freiwillige für.
Wir können Spielzeug erwähnen.
Wir können Spielzeug erwähnen?
Ach so, ja. Oh, ganz schlimm. CHW hat so geile Sachen wie zum Beispiel so Anlagen, wo sie Eisenbahn-Notbrücken auf- und abbauen können. Abgefahrenes Zeug, so große Wiese, Vielplatz, Kranplätze, verdichtete Kranplätze, noch unten Löcher, Dämme, Stahl, Betonträger, und da kann sie dann Eisenbahn-Notbrücken auf- und abbauen. Geiler Scheiß. Große Hydraulikzylinder, Spielspielzeug.
Die Feuerwehr hat sowas auch.
In unserem Konzept kann das das CRW auch bieten. Ja, wenn es so umgesetzt wird. Zum Beispiel die Leitstände. Man könnte doch Leitstände von Kraftwerken, die wir gerade ausbetrieben haben, kaufen zum Spielen. Und in so einer Halle stellen, Kartine daneben, Bade daneben, 20 Kisten Mate oder eine Bierpipeline. Und dann hast du da dein Spaß. Dann ist das ein Testzentrum, wo du Einsätze an Kraftwerksleitstätten üben kannst, der Staat bezahlt das. Und wir können endlich mal die Nerds in das Radaranlagen ranlassen.
Die Sendung ist jetzt fast über 90 Minuten lang. Und jetzt wird mir klar, dass das alles nur ein elaborierter Plan für einen neuen Hackspace ist.
Ein neuer Hackspace mit ganz viel schwerem Gerüst, woran du einfach im normalen Leben nicht kommst.
Aber trotzdem noch die Frage, jetzt ihr als Ag Kritis. Seid ihr jetzt sozusagen gesagt, wir sind 42, lasst uns mal machen? Oder kann man euch auch noch helfen? Also nicht Mitglied in einem Fleischrunden, sondern so.
Bitte mit Zucker oben drauf. Ja, nicht jetzt 5000 Mann, die einfach rumhören wollen, was wir so tun, sondern wir müssen halt auch Dinge tun, wie recherchieren, Blogpost schreiben, Awareness machen, auf Veranstaltungen uns anbiedern und einbringen, damit die Politiker auch mal zur Abwechslung zuhören, Medienarbeit und das alles erfordert natürlich viel Hintergrundarbeit, also wirklich diese Recherche, Analyse und so weiter. Und da können wir, wenn jemand da Lust und Laune zu hat, also man kann ja gerne mal auf unser Ag-Kritis-Blog gucken, da sind einige Paper und Fachartikel verlinkt, oder auch viele Podcasts und andere Artikel, wo Journalisten uns angefragt haben und wir dann Stellungnahme gegeben haben. Und all das kostet natürlich extrem viel ehrenamtliche Freizeit, wenn also jemand bereit ist, Lebenszeit abzuknappsen und das da reinzubuttern, herzlich gerne. Wir sind aber keine Aufklärungskonstellation für Leute, die wissen wollen, wie Kritis tut. Das kannst du im Rahmen deiner Recherche lernen, aber wir sind keine Austauschplattform für Leute, die wissen wollen, was ist Kritis, wie tut es. Das machen wir in Podcasts hier beispielsweise, aber eben nicht untereinander. Genau, also wenn du dich mit Kritis in irgendeiner Weise oder einem Sektor, einer schmalen Nische in diesem Bereich bereits tiefergehend auskennst, oder im beruflichen und privaten Alltag damit zu tun hast, und der Meinung bist, dass Grammatik und Texte schreiben eine wunderbare Ausdrucksform ist, dann bitte melde dich bei uns, dann bist du genau bei uns richtig. Oder wenn für dich Recherche nicht heißt, ich google mal kurz ein Wort und der erste Treffer ist Copy-Paste. Das ist wirklich wichtig. Wir müssen sehr detailliert im Hintergrund recherchieren, um so Szenarien wie Ijon hervorragend vorgeführt hat, wie viel Gigawatt wo, was ist eine Schnelllast usw. Du kannst da keinen Stuss erzählen. Jemand wird es gegenprüfen und sagen, was ist das denn? Das sind Labortaschen, die wollen hier irgendeinem Politiker ein Cocklat anzuortackern. Auf gar keinen Fall. Also wenn, dann hat das Hand und Fuß, was wir da von uns geben.
Was sind jetzt bei euch konkret die nächsten Schritte?
Die nächsten Schritte ist das Cyber-Hilfstab-Konzept weiterentwickeln. Wir haben jetzt nach der Defensive Con sehr viel Feedback erhalten. Input, außer Community, kritischen und konstruktiven, ganz toll. Wir sind dabei, diese Inhalte zusammen zu tragen und intern zu diskutieren, damit wir dann zur nächsten Version dieses Konzepts kommen. Das entsteht mehr oder weniger nach einem Konsensprinzip. Wenn wir uns alle finden, dass das so gemacht werden muss, dann schreiben wir das da so rein. Das dauert also alles ein bisschen so eine Änderung. Darüber hinaus beschäftigen wir uns mit diversen Themen, die der Cyber- und IT-Sicherheit zugrücklich sind und damit auch kritisch betreffend, aber im weiteren Sinne sind. Zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt gerade unseren Input zur Cyber- und Sicherheitsstrategie 2016 gegeben und in den Workshops teilgenommen zur Entwicklung der Cyber- und Sicherheitsstrategie 2021 im BMI. Das war ganz spannend. Und jetzt, wo wir die Berichte der Workshops heute bekommen haben, sind da auch ein paar Sachen tatsächlich hängen geblieben. Das möchte ich sagen, war Lobbyismus, wie er funktioniert und funktionieren sollte, das haben wir genau richtig und gut gemacht. Und das machen wir und dann schreiben wir Blogposts und versuchen, das in der Öffentlichkeit zu platzieren. Gastartikel, wir kriegen natürlich wieder TTC auch sehr viele Presseanfragen von Leuten, die irgendwas wissen wollen zu irgendwas. Manchmal beantworten wir die, manchmal schaffen wir das nicht.
Zwei Zeitfragen noch. Die eine ist, in welchem Zeitrahmen rechnet ihr mit dem Projekt? Also ist das so nächste Bundestagswahl, dann die Leute anquatschen, dann zwei Jahre später steht das Ding? Oder ist das eher sowas wie, das dauert alles, wir planen mal jetzt vorsichtig die nächsten zehn Jahre ein.
Ich glaube, jederzeit Angabe ist unseres. Wir reden mit Menschen in Behörden und hoffen, dass wir das nicht beschleunigen können. Eigentlich müsste man so ein Projekt, das ist unser Anlass nach hier vor, über Deep-State-Lobbying machen. Wenn wir die gesamte mittlere Ebene von allen relevanten Behörden überzeugt haben, dass das die richtige Idee ist, wird das von unten hoch gereicht. Und dann wird das irgendwann in einem Omnibus-Gesetz durch den Deutschen Bundestag gehen, wo 120 andere Gesetzesänderungen auch noch mit drin sind. So wie die Behörden das halt so machen.
Halt! Ich finde den Begriff Deep-State schwierig, weil der aus der Verschwörungserzählung kommt. Was genau meinst du damit?
Ich meine damit die unglaublich komplexen Verschränkungen der unteren und mittleren Behörden-Ebenen über alle Länder und Bundesbehörden hinweg.
Das muss man vielleicht wissen. Also staatliche Behörden werden gelenkt durch die parteipolitische Besetzung, die im Rahmen einer Bundestagswahl stattgefunden hat. Da arbeiten aber ganz viele Leute, die da immer arbeiten, egal wer sozusagen gerade eine Regierung ist.
Und wenn alle eine Meinung sind, dass man ein Thema jetzt aufmachen muss und anfangen muss, dann passiert da zumindest irgendwas. Dann bringt das irgendwann mit zur Politik durch.
Was ist ein Omnibusgesetz?
Ein Omnibusgesetz ist, wenn das BMI einmal eine Rundmeldung schreibt an alle nachfolgenden Behörden und sagt, was braucht ihr Jungs? Dann schreiben die einmal alle ihre Wünsche auf. Dann werden diese Wünsche zusammencopy pastet. Dann werden da in einem Gesetz 120 Gesetze angefasst oder so was und geändert. Und dann geht das in den Bundestag. Wird nach elf Kurs durchgewunken und dann haben die Behörden, was sie wollen.
Also ich lerne nicht nur, dass es so weit, dass es einen schwarzen Neustart gibt. Ich lerne auch noch Dinge über das Gesetz, die ich gar nicht wissen wollte. Anyways, wenn man jetzt bei euch mitarbeiten will, wie viel Zeit muss man mindestens bereit sein, sich ans Bein zu nageln dafür?
Na ich hätte jetzt schon gesagt, pro Woche vier bis acht Stunden sollte man einplanen. Das ist realistisch, oder Ijon? Ich finde, das ist halt ein bisschen hochgegriffen. Also so pro Woche vier Stunden fände ich cool. Wir machen zwei Wochen Mammel, ein, zwei Stunden dauert das. Alle zwei Wochen ermammeln wir zusammen und reden über, was wir vorhaben. Und wenn man dann darüber hinaus dann noch mal jede Woche so ein, zwei, drei Stunden in die AG stecken kann, dann ist das schon geil. Ich würde denken, dass du die, vielleicht zehn Stunden im Monat. Würde ich sagen. Du hast es doch noch mitgekriegt, verdammt.
Der Zerfall der AG-Kritis begann an dieser Stelle. Nein, Quatsch.
Da gehört schon mehr zu. Alles ehrenamtlich, alles freiwillig. Und wenn es mal an drei Wochen nicht geht, oder ein Monat oder drei, weil irgendwie Stress auf Arbeit ist, oder in der Familie, dann ist das so. Und sagt man Bescheid kann halt nicht, dann ist es halt okay. Alles ehrenamtlich. Das ist jetzt nicht so das harte Kriterium. Aber so eine gewisse Erwartaushaltung steigt da schon hinter. Wenn du mitmachen willst, dann machst du halt auch was und hörst dich nur zu.
Ihr könnt beides machen. Ihr habt jetzt hier zugehört. Ihr könnt dann bis mitlesen in den Show Notes. Verlinken wir euch die passenden Twitter-Accounts und die Webseite Ijon und HonkHase. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart und das so ausführlich erklärt habt. Und auch meine Fragen alle beantwortet habt. Danke schön.
Das Konzept dazu, wo ihr all das noch ausführlicher und konkret und ohne Erinnerungslücken und sehr konsistent daher argumentiert aufgeschrieben findet, findet ihr auf der Ag Kritis Webseite auch. Show Notes. Vielleicht das Konzept da auch noch mal explizit verlinken.
Profis am Werk, ne? und Lobby-Profis am Werk, merkt ihr selbst. Also, danke schön. Und ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, an euch hab ich noch eine Frage, nämlich die letzte Folge vom Chaosradio. War ja ein ganz anderes Format, als wir das normalerweise haben. Das war so featuremäßig, wie ein verstehbarer Hof besucht, beziehungsweise Danimo hat das getan und daraus ein schönes Ding gebaut, wie ich zumindest finde. Trotzdem würde uns natürlich interessieren, interessiert euch so ein Format, würde euch das weiter anhören, oder lauft ihr mit Händen über dem Kopf aus dem Raum, wie Honk Hake es in dieser Sendung beinahe gemacht hätte? Also, lasst uns da gerne auf allen Kanälen, auf denen wir unterwegs sind, Kommentare zukommen, weil uns das natürlich interessiert, wie ihr das findet. Und das soll es für heute von mir auch gewesen sein. Vielen Dank an das Team, die das ganz hervorragend vorbereitet haben. Ich fand es tatsächlich ein bisschen gruselig, weil zwei Tage vorher die ganze Sendung stand und das passiert normalerweise nicht. Ich hätte gedacht, irgendwas explodiert. Und bevor es das tut, gehe ich jetzt und sage nur noch, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.